the book version of this
entrepreneurship course was voted as the
number one most popular business book of
the year by business insider readers
chris herron created this course along
with the book that it's based off of
chris is a best-selling course creator
author business school professor and mba
graduate from columbia university
business schools do a pretty good job of
providing students with theoretical
frameworks which can sometimes be
applied to real world problems
however
quite often they overlook the most
crucial and practical business lessons
like how to network how to find
customers or how to get a job
if you want to learn how to get a
meeting with almost anyone or take your
career to the next level then this
course is for you
i've worked at goldman sachs
i've met with top business people
including bill gates warren buffett and
the founders of the biggest technology
companies and at the end of all my
meetings with these visionaries
i've always asked them for advice on
what made them so successful
and a lot of what they taught me is not
taught in business school so i put
together a list of every lesson and i've
included it in this book and in this
course
[Music]
these lessons will help you take your
career to the next level
it's exciting to reinvent yourself in
ways that you never thought were
possible
until you realize it is possible
anything is possible as many of my
students that have taken this course
i've realized
[Music]
[Music]
i put all of my business knowledge and
passion into this course
and i'm humbled to say
that business insider wrote an article
stating that my book 101 crucial lessons
they don't teach you in business school
was voted as the number one business
book of the year
also forbes magazine stated
that this book is one of six books that
every entrepreneur needs to read right
now
so let me teach you about these crucial
business lessons
let's step out of business school and
into the real world as we take your
career to the next level
[Music]
in november of
2015 uh one of my clients when i worked
full-time in venture capital had an
extra ticket to go to the tony robbins
uh event
called upw meaning unleash the power
within uh down in los angeles uh and so
i i i graciously accepted and i went
down
and in la i think it was at the staples
center or a very large convention center
there's ten thousand people in the
audience it was crazy it was awesome
and it was a four-day event
and we went through a lot of exercises
goal setting workshops etc
and then
including walking across hot fire coals
on the saturday night
and tony conditioned us tony robbins
and i actually ended up meeting him
another time for business really reasons
really nice guy but and when i shook his
hand his hand like wrapped around my
hand he's a big dude big dude but a
really nice guy as well
but what he did was on the saturday
night of that four-day event back in
2015
he
had us walk across boiling hot coals
like it looked like lava
and he conditioned us to
believe
in our mind that we're not going to feel
any pain at all
he conditioned us to do that and so i
walked across the coals
and i didn't feel any pain at all it was
exhilarating and of course i had lots of
fire hoses there just in case whatever i
didn't feel any pain it was amazing
uh and and i went back to my hotel it
was actually an airbnb that night uh in
in la
and i um i i couldn't sleep because i
was excited but also because there's
blisters in my feet and i had to take a
bunch of advil
my feet were fine though
but that that event kind of changed me
it really changed me and on the sunday
of that four day event uh what tony
robbins did was he said that
write down your goals
and he then said
i want you to think of one particular
goal
that you've been kind of putting off for
a while in your life
and what i want you to do is i want you
to write down that goal
and i also want you to write down a
deadline date
okay most most people don't set deadline
dates for goals
and so what i did was i was writing this
book for a couple of years you know uh
and it's this book back here of course
101 crucial lessons i don't teach in
business school
and
i
every time i met with somebody very very
successful i'd ask for advice and i
documented
and then what happened was um i wrote
down a deadline date that sunday before
i flew back home the fourth day of the
conference
and i wrote i'll finish this book in two
or three weeks
and i flew home
and it was a sunday night
then on a monday morning i went into
work
and there's three general partners of
ours in the firm myself included
and i i just wasn't into it my heart
wasn't into work that day
and so around noon that day on that
monday i said i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna go home guys i'll
i'll see ya i'm just not feeling it and
they were cool they're like all right
chris we'll see you tomorrow or whenever
right so
um and and i could do that because there
was there's three of us owned the fund
so i went home
and i started writing a little bit on
that monday
and then i couldn't stop it was like
that jerry maguire movie um and when tom
cruise was writing that business plan
and i wrote for three days straight
basically
and by wednesday
i
published the book i publish the book
and you all know how to publish a book
it's easy to do you can always go to
haroonventures.com
right book all lowercase but i published
it by that wednesday
and you know what wonderful things
started to happen to me in my life
um i felt exhilarated uh and i i ended
up not really going back to work i kind
of did for a while but i wasn't into it
but
it that that changed me that event and
that led me to want to just
live my life my own terms and embrace my
passion which is teaching and up to that
point i had been teaching during the
evenings at a couple san francisco bay
area business schools mba and undergrad
which i love doing and i would always
teach during the evenings and
i was never exhausted i felt like i just
woke up i felt alive i felt alive it was
amazing
uh and so what i want to do is um i
actually want to go through this book
and i created a bunch of exercises for
you
so
welcome to
e1-2
that's entrepreneurship semester one
class number two
and as always please make sure you have
the appropriate workbook open today
it's really important that you download
the book today or have it open in google
docs but it works for you you can use
google docs word or or or pdf because
it's over 50 pages today
and
within the book you'll see
on the cover page
that there's eight numbers and so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to go through uh the first eight
sections of the book and again there's
going to be plenty of exercises here as
well and as always i'll tell you exactly
when to go to the book uh and and when
to do the exercises let me just
rearrange my screen here and touch uh
there's a quote here um from this kind
of ugly guy who has awful doubt humor
um but he's a bit humble sometimes the
quote is the best entrepreneurs don't
think that the glass is half empty or
half full they believe that the glass is
overflowing
and i really do believe that you know i
always see the positives in life always
always always you know what we think we
perceive you know thoughts your thoughts
become reality
um so um yeah we're 28 through other way
through uh this this course right now uh
and so as i mentioned before um we're
going to go through this book this book
uh in a lot a lot of detail a lot of
detail and uh i published this um not
only on um on on kindle but also amazon
the print version uh and many of my
students uh i'm so happy to hear
uh have started to publish your own
books as well and i've got copies in
here
uh and i also published it on on on
audible.com i went to acx.com and did it
there and that's the cover of the book
from audible and i have the cover of the
book made by some dude um i can't
remember where he is actually no it was
a woman actually actually her name is
ultra contu
on fiverr.com and she's based in
bangladesh and she's great so she made
this cover yeah
yeah um and then uh what happened was
i'm humbled to say that uh per this this
video here um
it was
forbes wrote an article saying this is
one of six books every entrepreneur
should read right now along with lean
startup zero to one by peter thiel uh
the self-made um billionaire effect
start with why by simon sinek and the
seven habits of highly effective people
by stephen covey i actually went to
business school at columbia with stephen
covey covey's kit yeah
so this this kind of changed my life uh
this this book uh and i i was very
transparent in this book
and i find that it's easier for me uh to
read social media posts or books or
articles if they're very very short when
i was a kid i loved reading books by
roald dahl
he made james and the giant peach
and charlie in the chocolate factory and
that influenced me because roald dahl
that his chapters were very very short
it was just easy for me to to go through
it and that's what i did with this book
here as well i kept the chapters very
very short uh and i'm humbled to say
that it was also the number three
bestseller i think the kindle version
for a while on on on amazon it's still
it's since trailed off a bunch troll off
a bunch yeah
but i had a lot of fun put this together
so there's 17 sections in the book
and we're going to talk about the book
in two different parts and so as i
mentioned before
the first half of the book is today's
is in today's workbook we're gonna do
sections one through eight uh and then
next class um we're gonna do the second
half of the book and discuss sections
nine through seventeen okay so let me
show you what that means so if you go
here to to the workbook
um you'll see here that this is more
than 50 pages and it might be the page
link might be a little bit different
depending on how many notes you take
in this workbook
as well as if you're using it on a
different form factor or pdf version
or the the word version microsoft word
version but the contents are the same
and so what i'll do is i will ask you to
click on these numbers
every now and then to start doing
exercises and i'll make it very very
intuitive to know exactly how to do this
and when as well
and so
you click here
and then you click down here now
if you can't see a hyperlink here after
you click this then go up here and just
click section one two three etc and what
i did also
was
i put here the table of contents for the
first half of the book
and if you're using the microsoft word
version of this document or the google
docs version you can click on any of
these to jump right to these chapters in
in the book
um it doesn't work i don't think on the
pdf version so just scroll to where you
should be
so i included actually all of um
all the content of the book the first
half at least today and i'll include the
next half of the book in next class's
workbook so if you go here to section
one
i i talk about here high level what we
cover in section one
i had a lot of fun with 3d images today
too
and then if you want you can type your
notes here
for lesson number one
and below each
lesson title
is the actual text from the book and
don't read this
during class read it during during
homework or on the side if you want to
it's optional completely
so you can take notes here on on lesson
number one if you want to and what
you've learned
and what you can also do is if you go to
the next lesson here number two you can
take notes here again and again there's
a text here from that chapter they're
very short
and you have to read the entire thing
you can skim it or read another day
all right so let me go back here to the
top just we're on the same page does
that work oh yeah good
there we go good
all right so um as i talk about all 101
lessons in today's class and next class
as well um you can take down notes as i
just showed you
in in the uh
in the workbook you downloaded today
so let's start now with with topic
number one
so uh
section number one uh is called
relationships are more important than
product knowledge um and uh i have a
little catch phrase for all all the
sections in the book so the first cache
phrase for section one is crucial
networking tips to make you more
successful now
we've covered a bunch of this before so
i'm just going to go over what we've
already covered very quickly so i can
focus much more attention on the new
stuff but it's always important to
re-emphasize what i've taught you before
because
repetition is the mother of all skill
okay so the very first lesson is steve
jobs winning strategy uh how to get
anything you want
um and and if you're watching the replay
i mean the non-live version of this
lecture uh what you can do if you want
uh is
you can actually go to um
go to chapter one here or i should say
uh the uh lesson number one by going
here
and what you can do is just click on
this video here to watch a
short video of steve jobs uh and if you
don't want to click on this you can just
search for three words uh in uh in
youtube which are steve jobs ask
um and
you will never get anything you want in
life now if you don't ask
and when we were younger
growing up um we were kids
we asked our parents all the time for
stuff you know like my youngest one
drives me crazy i love them though he
says dad can i have some candy i'll say
no
literally a minute later he'll say can i
ask him kenny now
no and then he'll ask again like five
he's relentless relentless
uh and then what happens is you stop
asking once you've been conditioned to
stop doing that for whatever reason um
and and you can be tactful when you ask
and not overdo it and upset people
obviously but what happens is once we're
done with high school
for a lot of us when we go to a
university or or start our first job
whatever it is
we don't really ask for anything because
we learn that if we keep our heads down
and we get good grades
then everyone's proud of us and life
works better
but then what happens is many years into
your career
you wake up one day and you look around
and you think to yourself my goodness
why are all these other people around me
getting uh getting promoted
and not me
why are all these other less capable
people
around me getting raises and not me
and you realize and it might be too late
or it's never too late but sometimes it
it takes you to your 40s till you
realize this
that if you want a raise or promotion
you have to ask
nobody's ever made ceo or ever raised a
lot of money as an entrepreneur without
asking over and over and over and over
again
and do you ever see somebody that is is
kind of average looking
and uh their significant other is
unbelievably attractive
and
you wonder what's going on
why how did that happen and it's not
always about money okay
um it's it's because the the person
that's less attractive and and we we
refer to this usually as the matching
principle in psychology
you know people that are they're both
very good looking usually end up dating
but there's always
an exception and many exceptions and
it's not just about money
it's about the person who
is
maybe average looking or whatever
just thinking themselves
i've got nothing to lose and everything
to gain i'm going to keep asking people
out over and over and over again because
i know
that the pain from being rejected a
bunch of times is nothing
compared to the pleasure which is
massive
of being of this person saying yes to a
date so to speak you got to be
relentless and a lot of entrepreneurs
are like that as well
they're they're relentless they they
they just don't stop they're aggressive
they're aggressive and and they just
don't they really don't care what people
think of them either and that's why
they're very very successful they don't
give a damn what people think yeah
so
you got to be the same way as well sorry
my stomach's grambling trembling here i
got this new ninja bullet thing and i'm
it's my new diet here
kale blueberries etc gives me energy
so you got to ask
if you want anything in life you got to
ask over and over and over and over and
over and over again
kind of like michael jordan i feel over
and over and over again and that's why i
succeed
don't forget that please don't forget
that you got to ask
ask often be a pain in the neck and
don't give a damn if you get rejected
who gives a damn
you know jk rowling she you know she she
got rejected by like 29 or 30 publishers
she didn't give a damn that people
thought she was a failure who cares
on the 30th they said yes and she's a
billionaire now
all right let's move on now to number
two um how to get a job and why sending
in a resume can be a waste of time there
is a better way
but even if you have an amazing resume
and an amazing linkedin profile it's not
enough
you're gonna have to network like crazy
you're gonna have to do a ton of
informational meetings that's how you
get jobs in this new digital reality
that's just how it works
because if you apply online you're one
of a thousand people applying for a job
and the dude that gets the job is
usually the one that knows somebody at
the company
so and we've covered this a lot before
so i'm gonna skip over this one here uh
but your your your network is your net
your your net worth yeah
all right next up is uh business is
about people and not about what you know
um you know a big rookie mistake is
going to any business meeting and just
talking about business right away that
doesn't matter dude
it doesn't matter most jobs in the world
are sales
and
most ceo roles
you're a salesperson and if you're a
partner in a law firm
don't be a part of a law firm but if
you're a partner in a law firm uh or or
in a venture capital firm you're a sales
person as well
so how do they do it well they do it by
bonding and we've talked a lot about
this before bond before business
so business is about people
and and not what you know it's important
to reinforce that
now
what you have to do also is uh in in i
knew a guy
who is the head of government sales at
ibm in dc
and i had um i had dinner with him one
night with him and with uh mohit aaron
uh who's the founder of a great company
called cohisti when i was on mohit's
board
and uh it was a great it was a great
dinner we we had dinner in palo alto and
because this dude
was at ibm and in a very senior role
i asked him you know i said how did you
get to where you got
and he talked about how he learned a lot
from working actually in politics and i
said oh what do you mean by that he said
well in in the early 90s i worked for
george bush senior in the white house
and uh i was like oh my gosh this is
amazing i got to ask you questions
um and so i asked him i said can you
please give me
the most important lesson you learned
from work in the white house for bush
senior why was he successful
and this guy told me he said it's
because uh
bush senior would treat people like
celebrities and celebrities like people
so
if if you ever meet a celebrity or
somebody very senior in your company
just treat like a dream like a normal
person they'll feel uncomfortable if you
treat me differently
and if you meet somebody who's not so
important whatever on how you classify
what not so important means
treat them like a celebrity as well you
know ask a lot of questions ask them a
lot of questions you know where'd you
grow up and that sort of thing and just
just learn from them just bond
and don't forget to say people's names
at least once or twice during during a
longer conversation it's more personable
that way
and after you meet with anybody
um connect with them immediately on
linkedin as well and just remember their
name and while you're going off script
here but while you're talking to them
what you got to do is
you got to visualize and think about
how you're going to remember their name
and so
uh when i was 19 i actually did the dale
carnegie public speaking program
and
there's this woman named uh cynthia
mustachio
and i met her once there back when i was
19 like
ages ago last century
and her name was cynthia mustachio but i
remember thinking to myself every time i
see her i'm going to think she has a big
mustache
and so that's how i remember cynthia
mustachio
and you got to do the same thing as well
what you can do is you when you when you
meet people because it's really
embarrassing man like if you go to a a
party or something
and you forget somebody's name
it's embarrassing to just say hey you
which is what i do sometimes to be
intellectually honest
but what i what i do it's awful for me
it's the worst for me because my wife's
name is the same name as me her name is
christine i'm chris
so everybody remembers chris and
christine
and so we go to parties and and i i do
this actually this i probably shouldn't
tell you this trick i'm going there
anywhere i don't care fully transparent
as always
so if christine is beside me at a party
and there's somebody beside me and i
have no idea what their name is i forget
i go like this i scratch my neck and
then christine jumps in and introduces
herself
and at the end of the night i've lost
like eight layers of skin just kidding
on my neck yeah but it works but you got
to remember people's names and do name
association as well
if you can and so when you meet somebody
if their first name uh is uh similar to
a rock star's name or the same as a rock
star's name uh then just think of it
that way like if you meet somebody named
bob
um just just think of bob dylan you know
singing a song or in an interview saying
hey
you know you can't really understand it
but it's it's silly visualization i get
it but you'll never forget it yeah yeah
all right
all right uh next and and also um
not not just rock stars but think of i
think of actors as well when you meet
somebody or something really really
silly really silly like like cynthia
mustachio
okay moving on
all right next up um i want you to meet
people have fun and learn and there's no
reason why i threw in baby yoda here
other than the fact that i think that
baby yoda is adorable
um
no but in all seriousness um
when i went down to wall street to work
at goldman i was so nervous man i i was
nervous because i i thought and i
remember that time really well i had
nirvana's song in my head dumb
nirvana had it
one of the early albums it was great
there's a song called dumb
and it goes i think i'm dumb i think i'm
dumb and i remember when i was at
goldman i remember thinking to myself
if i don't say anything ever to anybody
they might think i'm dumb
but if i actually open my mouth and
start talking they'll know i'm dumb
and then the kirk cobain track would go
on and on and on in my head
perception becomes reality you got to
get that out of your mind and so i told
myself three things which assuaged my
concerns you know when i went down and
in hindsight i would have told myself
fourth and the fourth thing would have
been god already knows what's gonna
happen so just don't worry just enjoy it
don't question your faith
but the three things i told myself at
the time when i went down to goldman um
was and i and i loved the power of three
as you know uh in all my presentations
and in everything
um
you know
what i would say was uh i all i want to
do is i want to meet people
have fun and learn that's it
those are my goals
that's it
and it was great
because i met a ton of people my network
is amazing partially because of that
i enjoyed it i had fun i never saw it as
works i conditioned myself to enjoy it i
learned a ton and once you stop learning
you got to move on to another job
so if you're you're ever nervous about a
new job
don't worry because when you start a
brand new job i don't care how old or
young you are they're not going to give
you like mission critical stuff right
away
especially when you're younger you know
you're not going to show up first day
and they're going to say write me a
proposal on on if ibm should buy red hat
which they already did but you know what
i mean
um don't worry when you show up you go
through a training program or you'll
you'll get mentors whatever or you'll
photocopy like i did uh which i did with
pleasure because i read all the stuff
when i was photocopying when i worked at
accenture i learned
meet people have fun and learn
all right next up we've got the
importance of sincere gratitude
and so this is a a great book here by
the dalai lama called the art of
happiness which i i read on my honeymoon
actually um and i read this actually we
were in um we were in bali and i bought
the book and i read it there such a
beautiful place to read that book too i
loved it and the indonesian people were
so nice oh my god they're incredible
but read this book if you get a chance
because it will really help you
understand the importance of of of
gratitude you know be grateful for
something different every day
and with my kids um when i put them into
bed and we say prayers and my oldest one
andrew he's too cool for school whatever
i don't i don't do president anymore
he's but he's old or whatever but my
other two kids i do
uh and um during prayers i i asked them
to thank god every night for something
new
uh and so the
we've knew it for years it's i mean it's
getting crazy now they're like thank you
god for blue smarties but you know what
i mean if you're grateful for something
different see if we're still recording
okay good if you're grateful for
something different every single day uh
it'll get you into peak mental states
and so i practice gratitude
every day before i get up you know i say
prayer and i thank god for ten things in
this order always
andrew matthew dylan christine mom dad
jamie k elizabeth and my students you
you so anyway that that's what i do and
andrew matthew dylan are my kids
matthew andrew dylan m-a-d or dylan
andrew matthew
d-a-m yeah matter damn yeah yeah now
you'll never forget the initials of my
kids mad or damn there we go
so practice gratitude please a lot a lot
uh focus on
on on the beautiful things you have in
your life not the material things
but friends loved ones
you know your parents are gonna love you
no matter what happens no matter what
happens they're gonna love you forever
yeah and so your kids your spouse
whatever your buddies that sort of thing
be grateful for what you have and
don't buy things
by experiences
okay next up your alma maters okay where
you went to school the network matters a
lot and so keep in contact it's a
wonderful thing
because a lot of times you'll learn more
from your fellow classmates than you
will from your teacher it's true it's
true
so one of the best networks you can have
is a school network
and you don't have to go to harvard
business school for that
any network really any network so your
alma maters just remember that
okay
uh next up is a crucial post meeting
networking best practice
so it's really simple after every single
meeting you have in business for the
rest of your life
that day
i want you to connect with that person
or the people you met that day using
linkedin
please do it please do it um because
your your net worth is your your network
so to speak uh and when people size you
up uh and they look at at who you are
and which contacts you have in common if
you have a lot of secondary connections
with somebody meaning uh contacts in
common or whatever it is
um
then
they're they're more likely gonna take
you a little bit more seriously yeah
it costs you nothing too it costs you
nothing
all right um and then um
i think that's it yeah we're done now
with uh with section number one which is
relationships are more important
than product knowledge
and so what i want you to do now please
is i want you to go to your workbook
and i want you to click on number one
meaning section one okay on the front
page so i'll do that i'll come right
back here so if i'm the first page now
i'm going to click here on number one
and if you can't click on this for some
reason
then what you can do is just click up
here on section one it's the same thing
okay
so and that will take us right here to
section one relationships are more
important than product knowledge
okay now what i want you to do is i want
you to spend three minutes please right
now
writing down notes on how you can apply
the lessons that we just talked about in
section one to enhance your career and i
wrote here chris will show you how to do
this during class okay i guess i'll show
you how to do this during class
and i wrote that myself
so all you do is you just go here and
you just write notes it's that simple um
and if you're using the pdf version um i
actually set up this field here so that
if you type a lot of notes uh it'll a
vertical scroll bar will appear here so
you can keep writing notes forever
um so yeah take three minutes and what i
want you to do is
i want you to think about
how you applying the lessons in section
one can enhance or improve your career
or your life make you happier so what
you'll do is this is pretty easy you'll
write something here if you want to okay
it's it's optional
and then and you can read the the
chapters later if you want you can write
something here lesson two
it's optional and let me just go to five
here
um
oh six whatever yeah right right down
here the important sincere gratitude
type your notes here how this can
enhance your life okay
so just do that for um
up until
section two
meaning um do it for the first eight
lessons here and it's optional if you
don't know what to write in one of the
boxes just leave it or you can even do
it for homework
so you got three minutes to do this go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
section two be long-term greedy
use these crucial long-term strategies
and watch your net worth soar
so
this here
is
mars
in a cyber truck elon musk cyber truck
it's tough to see i i screwed up the the
graphic there let me go back here
but i included it for for a reason in
the 3d model
and i did it because uh elon musk
is so long-term focused
um that he ignored all the naysayers
when it comes to you know creating
battery operated cars
um he he ignored the naysayers that that
tell him that he shouldn't try to get
into the industrial
car market as well meaning trucks
he ignores the naysayers by thinking
about
colonizing mars
out there i know
but he's very long-term focused and
that's one of the many reasons why he's
extraordinarily successful
all right let's talk about the first
lesson here
the longer the view the wiser the
intention
and that's a wonderful street there that
graphic of uh lombard street which is
here in san francisco now it's a very
long and winding road
yeah so um you got to be very very
long-term focused and warren buffett
said the longer the view the wisely
intention i completely believe in it
you know you got to be very very
long-term focused
you know don't just
chase trends here and there you know
what's a hot market now with the hot
market tomorrow went up think longer
term write your 10 year goals out and
figure out how are you going to make
that those 10-year goals become a
reality be long-term focused
fill the gap just be long-term focused
and
the best entrepreneurs i know are the
ones that are very very long-term
focused
um so just just write down your goals
often and think longer term
okay next up uh we've got uh learn
earn return
watch this video here i'm on the board
of this charity watch this
we've always been told we're not smart
enough
they say we lack the talent to get to
the next level
that we don't care enough about our
community
together we breathe different
the air is different where we're from
it's a place where greatness is organic
and homegrown
where the journey to greatness is
watered and nourished with the sweat and
tears of hard work
humbly rooting the deep soils of
discipline and
sacrifice this place is not meant for
everyone we're a family and we set the
bar high
we push further than anyone else
we sacrifice anything at any time and we
live every moment chasing greatness
life skills performance is our game
changer we don't eat until everyone is
eating it's not about us anymore it's
about our family our community
academic performance is our ultimate
weapon
knowledge is power and it cannot be
taken away from us
sports performance is our secret
we don't train just to train we train to
be the best
mediocrity is not acceptable suck pain
is temporary quitting is forever
in our family we're hungry for greatness
hard work is all we know
we understand the difference between
good and great and that's why we prepare
so that no one can take away what is
ours
greatness inspires greatness at the limo
farm
[Music]
[Music]
so i'm very proud and humbled to say
that i'm on the board of directors of of
the the limo foundation it's an amazing
organization um and the founder there
david um who has given the speech he's
so inspirational he's amazing and
i believe that everybody deserves a
second chance and he always says that
you need to learn
earn and then return
and i completely believe it and let me
tell you a little bit more about david
because i think we all do deserve a
second chance
um so
david's brother is is on death row for
um
for yeah i'm not gonna go there but you
can probably guess why
and so uh david um he grew up um in east
palo alto
and east palo alto in america like in
america you get really rich area and
then kind of a scary neighborhood pretty
quickly it's just it's just it's a land
of extremes sometimes as much as i love
this country
but in east palo alto the high school
graduation rate is only 40
percent and there's there's a lot of
deadbeat fathers i don't think there's
such thing as a debbie mother
uh and so um david actually got a
scholarship uh to go to
a great school called juniperocera it's
a private all-boys school
and i was gonna send my kids there as
well um
and i went to an event there a charity
event and he gave a great speech
that inspired me and changed my life
in in that school there's a lot of
athletes there too like
greg jeffrey's great baseball player
went there so did barry bonds and
the best quarterback in history i can't
remember his name right now but you guys
all know his name
um
yeah he's dating gisele i think anyway
tom brady i think yeah but um
when i saw david give a speech there and
by the way i decided not to send my kids
to that school um i they all go to
public school
which is the
it's i think it's better than prep i
won't go there if you won't ask why i'll
i'm happy to go there too but but in
that that that uh that event uh david
was keynote speech speaker
um and he said something it changed my
life
um
and he grew up in in east palo alto and
got a scholarship to go to that school
but he said
don't expect
to accomplish your dreams in life
unless you help others accomplish theirs
first
let me say that again
don't expect to accomplish your dreams
in life
unless you help others accomplish theirs
first
i believe in that i really do
and and david has turned his life around
as well he actually spent time in jail
as well for robbing a safeway uh grocery
store here when he was a he was a kid
everybody deserves a second chance and
so what we do in the limo foundation
and i've donated a lot of money for
scholarships there etc i'll continue to
do so
is um what we do is the people that work
at limo
they'll they'll pick up these these kids
from
really poor areas uh in the morning
they'll give them full scholarships to
the best private schools
the best private schools
they'll drive them to school
then after school is done so they don't
get into trouble doing bad stuff or
whatever it is
after school is done they'll bring them
back to limo headquarters
which is close to east palo alto
and um
they have a sports facility as you saw
in that video and a lot of computers as
well
and then what they'll do is they'll help
the students with their homework if they
need help then they'll drive them back
home by seven or eight o'clock at night
and they do this every day every weekday
and it's a wonderful thing
because
you're giving a chance to to all these
underprivileged kids from tough
backgrounds and i love them to death
you know i i love them so much more
because they come from a tough
background
and there's potential everybody i got to
show you
going off script again but whatever
so i want to show you um these kids
they're amazing and the reason i i
created my course an entire mba one
course
was because of lima
so so what i did was if i go to my home
page
if i scroll down the bottom here
charity yeah it's here i think yeah
so yeah these are the cherries i'm ball
with so here's limo foundation
and
this is this is them they're amazing
they're incredible but there's also
pictures here i want to show you as well
so right here
this here is a it'll scroll through in a
second here
so this here is a picture of one of the
amazing limo students
uh and this is me in
january of 2016 a day that changed my
life
um and and what happened was i i told
david i said david
why don't we
why don't you let me teach all the limo
students on a saturday
and and i'll call it um an entire nba
one one day
and i hand made all these degrees for
them and that was at the end of that one
day and i gave my book as well now these
these kids are great uh and i want to
show you this actually this is this is
what i want to show you
the kids that were there that day
they ranged from the ages of of um
of nine
uh to 17.
and we spent 12 hours there and this was
actually in longitude capitals venture
capital headquarters in menlo park
it was uh
patrick one of one of the guys on the
board let us use his office good dude
uh and actually lilika right here um she
graduated she she's i think she was at
the san francisco art institute after
she finished high school and she's on my
board as well i'm proud to say and this
dude here is nine
and the oldest here was 17 at the time
and the whole day when i was teaching
them and the course is only eight hours
on udemy but the version here i made it
12 hours a bit longer
and the whole day when i was teaching
them this
every one of these kids including this
dude here who's nine
their eyes were wide open all day like
they weren't blinking they were just oh
my god like somebody's paying attention
to me this is awesome their questions
were brilliant
and what fires me up is getting people
that have been given a crappy set of
cards in life and helping them achieve
their dreams that fires me up that makes
me more happy than me accomplishing my
own dreams and there's potential in
everybody which is why i do what i do
and
all these kids have gone on to do
wonderful things wonderful things so far
and you know again this was back in 2016
in january
and i created these degrees for all of
them um yeah i went to an art shop and i
bought stickers it was fun and then what
happened was this that was on a saturday
then on i think it was a sunday i put my
course online on on udemy my mba course
and i think it might have been by a
monday or so that business insider wrote
an article that got shared hundreds of
thousands of times and it took off it
took off
uh and it changed my life
and
everything i do
like like teaching all of you
the genesis
is that day which changed my life right
there
don't expect to accomplish your dreams
until you help others accomplish theirs
first i really believe in that
and so david said learn earn return just
remember that make that the cornerstone
of your life as well and your philosophy
learn
earn return it's simplistic
and throughout your life like don't wait
until you're worth a fortune to return
you know
give give time as well
and i went to a columbia business school
and i remember it was a henry kravis
henry kravis is the number one private
equity dude in history and um
i'll show you i'll show you what it
looks like here
so he actually uh henry kravis uh
there's more pictures of the students
there
so henry kravis kind of created the
private equity market we kind of talked
about him a bit when we were doing that
that
that case study with all the hats with
disney a while back
uh but um henry kravis
he went to columbia and he was a
straight c student grades don't matter
that's right
uh and what he did was he actually um
he came to school and i was really
excited because i thought that
henry kravis was going to talk about
deals
and i read a great book when i was a kid
called barbarians at the gate which
talks about how henry kravis and others
bought uh
nabisco which stands for the national
biscuit company took it private made a
fortune
and so he showed up at columbia one day
to lecture and and instead of warren
buffett one day too which is cool that
he's also an alum there
and i couldn't wait to learn about deals
and
he talked for an hour and a half
all he talked about was just
not giving money but giving your time of
course he donates money too
but giving your time
uh and and i gained a tremendous amount
of respect for him and he's totally
right he's totally right you gotta
you got to donate your time and do
charity work throughout your entire
career okay you really really do um and
if you give you will get
it's prophetic it's true it's been true
since being a time
you know give and you will receive
so just remember that
learn
earn return
and to quote david for the limo
foundation before we move on to lesson
11.
don't expect to accomplish your goals or
dreams in life
until you help others accomplish theirs
first
all right next up is number 11 the
harder you work the luckier you get
all right and that's of course a
four-leaf clover
it's true though like you will get a
break
you will get a break
um you know
if you're working your ass off and
nothing is working out for you in your
life
nothing
just keep at it
keep at it you will get a break
eventually
you know like michael jordan said i
failed over and over and over again and
that's why i succeed
you will get your lucky break i promise
you
you will one day and you look back and
you'll be grateful to god
that
you had these potential failures or
career setbacks early on because it
actually guided you down a different
path in life you might not understand
that now
but i promise you will one day i promise
you
you know years ago i was down and out
i did everything right i worked for
somebody i made him a fortune
um he took all the credits
and people loved me on the team
and i was probably too good at my job
and so yeah you know what he did to me
and i remember calling my dad i said dad
i don't get it like i work so hard
you know and and i try to be a good
person
i try to give back and mentor and do
what i can do and i made the company so
much money and this shark
you know this this awful person who i'll
never name it's just i'll turn the other
cheek i guess
but i i told my dad about it and he's
like chris you won't understand this one
day but you'll look back years from now
and and you'll be grateful uh that it
happened because somehow it set you down
a different path
i said dad that doesn't make any sense
um
and i said it respectfully obviously i'm
very respectful of my parents
and then my dad he said chris what i
want you to do is go to the old
testament
the old testament is kind of the basis
for many great religions whatever
and he said i want you to read the book
of job
which is prophetic because jay would be
his job it's about this guy that lost
everything
and he didn't
lose his faith
and then much much later years later
everything worked out for him and he
kind of understood why things were the
way they were so
the harder you work the luckier you get
you will get that lucky break okay just
remember to keep failing over and over
and over again and not giving a damn
what anybody thinks
and i promise you i promise you i
guarantee it
you will get your lucky break
the harder you work the luckier you get
all right next up is the most important
investment you will ever make
the most important investment you'll
ever make is investment in you
don't ever be cheap when it comes to
education
so if if there's a book you want to
download or read and you're like i don't
know man it's like it's like 10 bucks i
don't know if i should
don't be cheap
just do it
you know subscribe to audible.com it's
like 10 or 15 bucks a month you can
listen to two books every month from i
don't know whoever your
whoever your inspirations are listen to
biographies or autobiographies on
successful people they share their
blueprint with you they give give give
give gift
you know they put they let their cards
be seen by everybody because they've
already made it and a lot of people that
are very very successful
the reason they were successful or
became successful is because they gave
remember in the first couple classes we
talked about that book give and take
and how the richest 1 people in the
world
you know are our givers
the middle 98 percenter takers
and the poorest one percent of my
favorite uh the mother teresa's of the
world that were
never concerned about making money
whatever yeah
it's so funny though because
it's coming full circle now but mother
teresa
there's this guy
that went to that school sarah that
david from the limo foundation went to
and so the first year i went to that
that charity event at limo or a party at
sarah and i saw dave give that speech
where he said don't expect to accomplish
your goals or dreams until you help
others accomplish theirs first
the second year i went back as well as
another charity event and i donated
again i didn't send my kids to private
school because i think public school is
better better
but the second year when i was there the
guy that gave the keynotes
and it was a tough act to follow because
david's amazing
the guy that gave the keynote was a guy
that went to sarah as well who was um
who was mother teresa's photographer
so um and and he showed us some
wonderful pictures i got to show you
something give me i'm going off script i
i don't give a damn um i'm gonna
stand up here in my my lululemon sweats
uh and walk around and find something to
show you
i almost fell down there but i'm okay
all right um
here it is
see if it's in the picture i think it is
um mother teresa said peace begins with
a smile
i love that it's so true
it's so true
peace does begin with a smile i i love
her to death lover did that somebody's
got to make a great movie about her
she's
probably my probably one of my favorite
people that ever ever walked this great
earth i'm so humbled to say i walked
this earth at the same time she did i
never got to meet her yeah but but she's
wonderful she's wonderful and i'll put
this up here actually
yeah actually i'll put it right here so
you can see both quotes
okay
all right
and this here by the way if you're
curious is how um we can tell if the the
color is correct when we go into post
edit so i have it face every single
camera
just to make sure that the color matches
because when i change the colors behind
me it messes up the pigment of my skin
sometimes yeah yeah yeah
all right
because in some videos i look like ernie
or bert
all right
all right next next up is um
yeah oh oh yes so in terms of the most
important investment you'll ever make
it's an investment in you um education
always always always don't ever be cheap
when it comes to education if your dream
was to go to i don't know yale medical
school
um and you know yeah
you're worried about the money
don't be just get in first and then
figure it out you'll figure it out
i actually
there's this one guy i was friends with
growing up and his mom used to always
brag about him yeah and and his name was
uh was was rick
uh and
he got into yale and his mom was
bragging
saying uh you know you know my son
he got into jail
so if your goal is to go to jail or or
yale
uh then um but but the money's an issue
just get in first and you you get a
scholarship you'll figure it out
if you want something bad enough in life
you'll always figure it out always
figure it out but when it comes to
smaller things
in life like you know buying a book for
education if you're on the fence just
buy it dude
just do it just do it don't be cheap
when it comes to
investing in yourself it's the best
investment you'll ever make in yourself
all right next up we've got uh learn
what not to do
um and i had so much fun creating these
graphics here
uh and and i was that guy that
didn't watch game of thrones for years
because i tried and then my kids were
around so i'd have to turn it off and i
try again later and there's eight
million different characters and i just
couldn't keep up there's too many
characters man it's complicated eh
uh and so uh i included that the bad
dude there um
something walker ice walker or something
yeah bad guy and i show him because i i
worked
for people
that
should not be managing people they're
they're awful awful people to work for
and i did learn from them because i
learned
what not to do
and so my attitude could have been
negative forever
but i told myself you know what
two things number one i'm learning how
not to treat people
and number two
this guy's such a jerk
that he's actually helping me because
he's motivating me
to you know
work hard on getting a better job and
improve myself so i'm never complacent
so when you work for other people learn
what not to do
as much as possible as much as possible
all right i think i'm going to take that
down because i'm not sure about the
glare i think it's fine but it might
mess things up here but just remember
peace begins with it with a smile yeah
and i've got this great quote here which
which i used to use in a lot of my
keynotes
um
and it's from a great poet american poet
um
a real renaissance man actually
um and he lived here in san francisco
for a while his name is mark twain uh
and a lot of people don't realize that
san francisco although it's california
is not warm
you know it's cold especially in the
summer the warm season's the fall
and so mark twain once said the coldest
winter i ever spent was a summer in san
francisco
but mark twain also said
the two most important days in your life
are number one the day you're born
and number two the day you find out why
and hopefully through the soul-searching
process of this entire mba degree
including today's class next class on
101 crucial lessons my book hopefully
that will help you to find your why
okay
all right so learn not what not to do
when you work for schmucks there is
light at the end of the tunnel and it is
not an oncoming train
all right so we are now done uh with uh
with section two
so what i want you to do now is
another exercise
so just go here
click on section two or go up here and
click on section two
and then what you're going to do is um
just take a couple minutes to write down
here your thoughts on
how thinking long term can help your
career
do the same for learn earn return if you
want to as well as the hard work you'd
like you get
all the ones here in number two up until
you see section three here okay great so
you've got three minutes to do this go
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
section three avoiding burnouts
i wrote here at the top avoid these
crucial landmines and save your career
and your life and it's killing me that
there's no end of quote there or the end
of bracket at the end there but that's
good enough i'm going to leave it here
because i want to prove a point that
you'll never accomplish anything in life
if you try to be a perfectionist okay if
if you want to
don't be a perfectionist if you want to
vlog or blog or create some sort of
youtube video
and what's holding you back is you don't
publish it because it's not perfect and
you care what people are going to think
screw it just do it as sir richard
branson says screw it let's do it so i'm
going to leave that that parenthesis oh
my god i talk a lot i'm going to leave
that parenthesis or close bracket out of
it there so avoid burnout is section 3.
and it is getting hot in here
speaking of matches
all right so uh lesson 14 is what to do
the second you return from vacation
and i worked when i was at goldman years
ago one of my clients uh rhonda chang
just a brilliant woman that worked at
manulife which is a big insurance
company that's canadian most people
don't realize that
and i was kind of stressed out and she
said chris let me give you some advice
and of course i didn't take her advice
but i listened to it
her advice was this the second you come
back from vacation
what i want you to do is i want you to
open up your calendar
and
book your next vacation six months out
that's the first thing you should do
when you come back from vacation open
your calendar and book your next
vacation six months out otherwise you
will burn out you will burn out yeah so
it's um
and it's i i gotta keep remembering this
too so the second you return from
vacation i want you to book your next
vacation
all right next up is uh stress will kill
you don't be the gazelle
i was watching national geographic years
ago
and it was this poor gazelle being
chased uh by by by a a i think it was a
cheetah or a tiger i can't remember
and
the gazelle was not caught thank
goodness
but national geographic put sensors on
the gazelle to monitor the gazelles
heart rates and other bodily functions
and what happened was this
the gazelle was running for their for
the for its life
and so obviously the heart was pumping
really fast you know pumping quickly
getting as much blood as possible you
know circling around the body
and what happened was the heart and the
mind
focused entirely on survival
and as a result
the heart and the mind i guess somehow
shut down the immune system while the
the gazelle was running
running for its life and the heart and
the mind
also shut down the reproductive system
and the gazelle aged a bit when it was
being chased as well
so the reproduction of functions shut
down
it aged faster
and also it could get sick quicker
because
all the heart and mind was focused on
was pumping more blood
and surviving that's stress stress can
kill you and so the only reason we're
supposed to feel stressed like that in
our lives
is if you know going back to caveman
times or whatever you're being chased by
a dinosaur or whatever it is somebody
that wants to take your life that's when
you feel stress
not all the time at work
a lot of times stress is up here
you know i i
i feel stressed probably because i'm
making myself stressed so don't be the
gazelle just chill out man
and what happens is conceiving having a
baby is not it's not as easy as most
people think
um that that haven't had kids before
you know we're we're very blessed that
you know christine and i got pregnant
pretty quickly with with all three three
boys we wanted to have a daughter as
well and usually people that have two
kids have a girl and a boy and they're
done
um but anyway i love all three of my
boys the same um but if we had a
daughter be it'd be it'd be awesome too
it'd be awesome too
wholly off topic but a lot of people
when they're trying to conceive trying
to have a child it's so stressful
and i remember for christine and i too
the first time we want to have a kid
there was a pregnancy test she bought it
and the second i we found out she wasn't
i was like damn it it was stressful
you know because it's why are we here
you know it says it's
kids that's one of the reasons the why
right but and then eventually obviously
things worked out great for us
but we have friends that have tried
everything in vitro spending a gazillion
dollars whatever trying to have kids and
it's so stressful in their marriage and
then they they conclude that
maybe we just can't get pregnant
and they do something wonderful they
adopt
adoption's a beautiful thing
and then what happens is after they
adopt this happens a lot
a couple months later they get pregnant
naturally
because they weren't feeling stress
don't be the gazelle please
don't be the gazelle just
just chill out it's all up here a lot of
the stress you're doing it to yourself
you're doing it to yourself
it's all up here perception becomes
reality
so just condition yourself
not to be stressed
and maybe what you do every day is
let me go back here
every day on on your daily sheet here
you do what i do which is when i wake up
in the morning
the first thing i do is um well i say
prayer but i also thank god for 10
different things
maybe what you do is part of your your
daily sheet here you you can change this
if you want to and at the end of today's
lecture i'm going to remind you where to
go get this and how to change this in
powerpoint or other programs but you can
change it so that this is your gratitude
section here so you write down what your
gratitude about or get rid of that
section and have a gratitude section
whatever it is along with writing your
goals and your schedule for the next day
as well okay
don't be the gazelle please
all right
avoid burnout avoid burnout yeah
all right next up we have got um when to
take a day off when you are not sick
this is important dude so
are you ever kind of in a bad mooc
because you're kind of i don't know
you're kind of stressed at work and
you didn't get enough sleep whatever and
things aren't going that great at home
temporarily
and so
you're not feeling great mentally
physically you're fine
but you go to work
and you go to work and
you might
not be as nice as always
put it mildly
or you might be a little bit cold to
somebody at work
or you might be
you're supposed to give a presentation
and
a lot of important people are around and
you just
stressed out
man you should never have shown up to
work that day to begin with
and so i think it's important to take at
least one or two days off a year
when physically you're not sick
but mentally you're not all there
it's important
and
you can tell people you're sick because
you are
you know
you're mentally kind of just feeling
burned out
it's a great investment to make yourself
and i made this red the bottle here red
on purpose uh supposed to be pills
um
it looks like it's clothing red on the
outside i put the wrong thing on it
whatever but but it on purpose to make a
point just it's a sense of urgency when
you're mentally drained
do not
whatever you do do not go to work that
day
whatever you do is going to hurt you
more than help you
all rights
lord oh this is the ten commandments
these laws
unto thy people
hear me
oh hear me
all pay heed
the lord the lord jehovah has given unto
you these fifteen
like
ten ten commandments for all to obey
i love that that was one of the first
movies i ever saw uh when i was a kid it
was called history of the world part one
uh by mel brooks and my dad took me the
movie i don't think he realized it was
gonna be
some parts weren't supposed to be
supposed to be shown to kids but that
was before uh indiana jones in the
temple of doom came out in 82 or 83
because that movie indiana jones off
script whatever
indiana jones in the temple of doom that
was the
that was the first movie that was um
uh that that that should not have been
pg it should have been a a which they
got rid of and so because of temple of
doom they created something called pg-13
which is another category of of of
raiding movies but that was uh that was
uh mel brooks obviously very very funny
man um and so i i
i bring up the ten commandments it's not
a religious thing here but um you know
those ten rules are the basis for a lot
of laws in in many wonderful countries
and the basis for a lot of religions too
but
when those 10 rules were made thousands
of years ago
one they they knew our four mothers and
forefathers that we need to take time
off or we'll burn out it's human nature
which hasn't changed in thousands of
years and you know
the rule is to
rest on the sunday or saturday or
whatever it is just one day a week
one day a week
you got to take off that one day a week
at least
and spend time with your family uh and
you know just get
just just focus on getting yourself
centered so to speak get outside your
body and kind of take a look uh
see the forest from the trees
um where are you in your life and what
are you here for anyway and you know
what what what's your why what's your
long-term goals are you happy at work in
your relationships whatever
um are you bonding enough with your kids
because by the time your kids are 13
years old you've already are 12 years
old
you've already spent 90 of the time
you'll ever spend with them so just
that's precious man like screw work
if you can every now and then you know
just
skip work to go to mommy or daddy daddy
child breakfast day at school because i
missed andrews years ago
and i don't know why i must have had an
important meeting that was so important
i can't remember it today but i do
remember missing andrew daddy day at
breakfast at school um so anyway
you can't get that time back and take as
many pictures as you can too before your
kids get old just savor every second
because they go fast man
and
my third son dylan my youngest son he
said dad
why is it
there's not as many pictures of me as
there are from my older brothers andrew
matthew
and i said of course there's enough it's
the same and he counted them too right
smart kid
so i went to bed that night and i woke
up
and i looked at my night table
and
there are actually a couple pictures of
him and me put in frames he went and he
found them
and they're still there now and this was
years ago years ago yeah you you can't
get that time back
uh so just remember that uh
you will burn out
if you don't take time off
uh it doesn't matter what what religion
you are and who cares it's you gotta
take one day off a week at least or you
will burn out and they say that god
rested on the seventh day and dude even
there's this there's this uh amazing
company uh that's uh it's it's in new
york city
and it's where i buy a lot of my uh my
photo equipment from
and it's called uh b h
uh and i bought actually uh this camera
here from from b h and a lot of my audio
equipment as well
this dude as well i buy from amazon too
uh b h is in new york city
and it was founded in 1973
and it's it's amazing great customer
service great prices uh they always have
stuff in stock if they can't they'll get
it for you immediately like these the
lights i'm using up above here
they couldn't find them anywhere they're
out of stock everywhere and i called
them and they walked through walls for
me there they're the best
but
you cannot buy anything
from them when the sun goes down on
fridays
so let's go there right now actually
it's 2 21 in new york or san francisco
time which means it's 5 21
new york time um i don't know if they're
they're probably
they're probably still let's see you can
you can put stuff in your basket but you
can't buy it b h and i want to show this
to you because i want to impress upon
you just how they're so awesome and they
still take off a day a week and they're
still amazing
so um let me see here is it sundown yet
not yet not yet but i'm just going to
put something in a basket for fun okay
let's go here to microphones okay
and let's go to
i've actually got that one running right
here as well on this camera
yeah and this one too scary all right so
watch this add to cart let's see what
happens
okay
view cart
okay it's still open now but if i were
to do it you could try this yourself in
an hour from now it would not work it
wouldn't work so anyway
a little on top there okay great so we
are now done uh with uh
with section number three
uh and so the exercise is go to your
workbook and click here on number three
okay uh and oh there's a mistake there
that's my mistake you won't see this in
your version but i have to change the
hyperlink so the way you do that is this
so you go here let me just delete the
hyperlink
you go here and you and it's similar in
word as well you go to link
and the way you link it is it looks at
the table of contents like heading ones
and heading twos
so what i want to do is i want to put in
section three give me a second section
three there good
a plea reply
click here
good yeah cool so go here uh and take
three minutes to to complete uh all the
lesson boxes here if you want to again
it's optional um so you got three
minutes to do this go
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's move on to topic number four
so topic number four is called create
off the charts confidence wear that
superman cape
uh and at the top there it says
crucial confidence lessons to help your
career take off i love this section i
love this section because
confidence is entirely up here it's a
light switch just flick it on just flick
it on okay
all right
so
the first lesson that we're going to
talk about here
in section number four is that
there are no limits
there are no limits and that's a ford
mustang down there because
henry ford said
um whether or not you think you can do
it
you are right let me say that again
whether or not you think you can do it
you are right
it's all up here i know it sounds so
simplistic
so simplistic
but confidence is merely a light switch
so just remember the past does not equal
the future
so
if something brings you down confidence
wise it never happened
erase it from your mind or at least
don't think about it at all
whether or not you think you can do it
you're right it's all up here there are
no limits except the limits that we set
for ourselves
okay number 19 is the glass is
always full always full and for those
you're not familiar with that term
there's a saying that
if somebody sees a glass that's that has
water up to the halfway mark
negative people will say the glasses
have empty and positive people will say
no the glass is half full
so perception becomes reality you know
it's like the rodan sculpture i think
therefore i am
and so this glass here um is not
half full
it's it's overflowing in my mind
and people think that i'm naively
positive
but i think the most positive people in
the world are the only ones that can
change the world okay i think all of you
if you're very positive you can put your
dent in the universe and change the
world as well so i got to be careful
because this thing is really overflowing
whoa
all right the glass is not half half
full it's overflowing my cup overfloweth
with optimism
all right next up we have got um a
balanced life means a more it means
you're more productive
in business
um
and we talked about this before so i
don't go into much
too much detail on that but
you know there's there are many people
in life that are incredibly well-rounded
you know they they're in great shape
they have a great family life
um you know they've got a great social
life they do well at work
uh they're happy because they're
balanced because they're balanced um and
so if you're balanced and if you take
your breaks as well i mean take that one
day off per week uh then you'll be much
more successful as well let me go i want
to go back and i'm really curious to see
if uh
b h is open right now and and i have to
bring this up because i mean this
inspires me dude so b and h again they
take that one day off a week
let's see here
um since 1973 it looks like no there's
they're still they're still open but i
will come back to this in a little while
uh let's go begin checkout i'm not going
to buy this obviously okay it doesn't
say anything yet okay but once we're
sundown uh in in new york that's when
this will this will uh go to
they'll shut it down okay sundown in new
york i know it's crazy
um but it's 701 p.m okay so three
okay so an hour and 15 minutes i'll i'll
try again later
but if you're balanced in life you'll be
much more productive and don't forget to
fill out that daily schedule as well
because that will help you be much more
balanced
all right let's move on number 21
there's luigi that's from luigi's
mansion okay um number twenty it's great
having kids because you get to be a kid
all over again yeah
um so number 21 is you're never as
nervous uh as you sound
um you know although you might not think
you're confident and you might think you
don't look confident when you're up
there on the stage in front of the world
when you feel nervous you don't look or
sound nervous don't worry about it don't
worry about it and who gives a [ __ ] when
anybody thinks you anyway
i don't care that's what you got to tell
yourself
okay luigi
all right next up uh we've got avoid
those people okay and i had to have
another video game
uh reference here not just nintendo but
this here is for i guess ps4 and an xbox
uh that's a character who i'm
embarrassed to say is canadian in the
game his name is trevor he's a bad bad
person
and he is from grand theft auto 5.
and i'm smiling because in one scene he
has a canadian accent as he takes on the
u.s military it's a little bit funny but
he's a bad dude
and you got to avoid those people
and when i say those people i mean
anybody that that hurts your confidence
or brings you down
you know you're you're
you're not a tree you can move
move away from these people cut them out
of your life that's right
that's right get them out of your life
you know if you've got a little bird on
your shoulder
um or a devil or whatever it is saying
you're not good enough you're not good
enough you're not good enough
get rid of that person get it out of
your life
get that person out of your life so
avoid those people
and go with your gut your gut is always
right you know when you're a lot younger
like i was it was you know 10 strikes
you're out now it's one strike you're
out or maybe two sometimes
but just avoid anybody in your life that
makes you unhappy
get them out of your life
you know get them out of your mind
they don't own you they can't control
you
get rid of them that's right
change your environment you'll change
your life as well somebody brings you
down just get rid of them man get rid of
them so anyway
see you trevor
all right
all right this
number 23 is that person speaks gooder
than me and he's supposed to have
glasses there i think i cut them off and
i was trying to get rid of the
transparent background there yeah
so
don't ever get intimidated
by people that
you think might have a better vocabulary
than you
or people that might have a different
accent than you
don't be intimidated by them
because a lot of times the reason why
they might be well spoken
is because they're very arrogant
or maybe they went to a great school
because their parents went there and
it's legacy that's how they got in
just because somebody sounds
confident or arrogant
don't let the perception be that that
fools you that they're right
uh or more often
right than you are
you know confidence does not lead
to uh to competence it might lead to
perceived competence
but not confidence in general so don't
don't ever get intimidated by anybody
that that speaks gooder than you at all
has nothing to do with success in life
it just bring you know it might have
something to do with they were born with
a silver spoon in their mouth
and and i'd rather not hire somebody
that was born with a silver spoon in
their mouth
because they're entitled i want somebody
that's poor smart and hungry or somebody
that's humble that's important to me so
don't ever get intimidated by that and
my dad actually he uh when he immigrated
from from egypt uh to and i didn't know
my dad had an accident until i was like
20 or so or 19 or 18 when i moved out
um he sounds a bit like james earl jones
uh this is cnn or or simba's father or
whatever
um but but i remember my dad told me
when he first moved to canada it was
really frustrating because he had to
support himself by by he immigrated in
1967 he left egypt
and he bribed an army official
to get him to fail the eye exam for the
crazy
army or whatever was some stupid war in
the middle east in 67.
so my dad came to canada and in order to
pay for himself here support himself
before he met my mama
um he uh he worked in a hospital
cleaning test tubes and the nurses would
all make fun of him uh because of his
accent and he couldn't speak the
language that well
uh and uh
you know he he could have just kind of
given up
uh or or just kind of accepted it and
had it killed his confidence
but uh
he didn't he channeled that frustration
uh and started his own company and so in
hindsight i'm sure he's happy uh that uh
that that happened yeah yeah so anyway
and then he met my mama my mom is
actually was a nurse or she isn't yeah
she's still alive she she was a nurse
and my dad's pickup line was uh
jackie do you have a tylenol he asked my
mom for tylenol my dad's a doctor yeah
so anyway we love you dada
so don't get intimidated by anybody with
a different accent or someone speaks
gooder than you because they're probably
entitled dude and
you peel back the onion a couple layers
and they're nothing compared to you
all right um and just remember number 24
is
nobody is smarter than you
okay and
in the book i i think i put a a link to
um let's go here to number 24. it's
lesson
number 24.
yeah here it is here
yeah i have a link here to a a short
video from steve jobs that will change
your life it's like a minute or two long
um
how nobody is smarter than you and once
you realize that i'm not telling you to
be arrogant but once you realize that
you're money you know i i believe you
and i believe in you
once you believe in yourself
you'll never be the same you'll never be
the same because you'll be able to
accomplish anything you want to in life
just remember that nobody is smarter
than you okay
just remember that confidence is
everything dude it's everything
everything
like i remember when i grew up in canada
and um i was kind of reserved a little
shy canadian
uh humble proud of my roots um and i
remember it was it was the 80s
and
ronald reagan was my hero
and i remember though that the
the cover of newsweek and time magazine
at the time was the downfall of the
american student
and how the american student is 50th in
the world of math and 50th in the world
in science it's a downfall of the
american student
and every couple of years you see the
same stupid headlines americans are 25th
or 50th in math whatever sciences
it doesn't matter
and i learned something when i started
um
when i started teaching here
during the evenings years ago
in the san francisco bay area and about
50 percent of my students at least were
born overseas okay so this is not an
american thing what i'm about to say
but yeah about 50 percent of my students
and about 50 percent of people live here
in the bay area and about 50 of the
founders in the bay area and about 50
percent of the engineers here in the bay
area were born overseas you know people
like pierre omidjar the wonderful
humanitarian he's uh he's he's person
he's from iran and of course he founded
ebay you got elon musk who splits his
time uh between here actually owns a
house not too far away from me now here
in hillsborough uh he splits his time
between here in southern california but
but elon musk
who also lived in canada for years but
but he's from south africa yeah you got
um
sergey brin and one of the brilliant
co-founders of uh
of google was born in russia
um so you've got this this beautiful
cross-cultural diversity here in the bay
area but one thing i discovered when i
started teaching here is that
american students
american students
whether or not you're born in america
doesn't matter but american students are
number one in the world in the most
important economic category
that nobody talks about
and that category is confidence
you know with confidence comes the
ability to sell
sell a dream like like like like tucker
does and there's the car version over
here yeah
um
with confidence comes the ability to
make something boring that's virtual
that you can't see feel or touch like
cloud software sound exciting think
about it think how boring cloud software
is
dude it's boring you can't see it it's
up there somewhere in the cloud it's
elusive whatever
but you've got these great entrepreneurs
out there that sell it
and they make a killing
because they come across as confidence
when they're delivering
so confidence leads to
at least
to competent sometimes too not over
being overconfident and of course
i know that
talking about the american angle some
people overseas might think that's
arrogance
it's it's that's not what i'm getting at
it's not like i've got to do a joke now
here we go this is awful kids
my american students are going to hate
me but i'm american now so i'm allowed
to do this
how does an american screw in a light
bulb oh my god i'm going to regret
saying this i'm just one dumb comment
away from just
everybody hating me
well here in america me as an american i
hold a light bulb and the whole world
spins around me
okay i'm totally i'm totally kidding oh
my god i've alienated my students i'm
totally i love all of you okay i'm
joking joking okay how does a a a dumb
canadian me screwing a light bulb i hold
it up there you go okay we're good now
we're good
but confidence uh it can be borderline
arrogant sometimes you got to keep your
confidence in check or just remember
your humble roots and like steve jobs
said you know stay foolish stay humble
i i should i have to i should probably
edit that out but f and i'm not going to
sorry matt matt my editor he's american
i love you matt you know i love you
right your family familia
yeah so um but no i i i do think a lot
of american whether or not they were
born in this country okay american
students
um see american students that were born
overseas they also think they can hold a
light bulb up okay
but american students are number one
in the world the most important economic
category which is confidence which which
lets you sell
because a great entrepreneur great ceo
etc they're great sales people
i'm gonna shut the hell up but now about
this one but nobody's smart in you
remember that
all right so we are now done uh with
with section number four
uh and so now it's time for the exercise
so go to your workbook
um and then just um and you can even
click in the in the footer here go to
section four does this work
there we go yeah that's someone's gonna
double click it yeah
uh and and i had a blast making this bit
this visual here man that was fun
um but but what i want you to do is just
go through all the lessons here
in um in section four and you can read
that text later if you want to
and just write down you know spend three
minutes and write down how
how what can you apply in the lessons
here in section four
to to enhance your career you've got
three minutes now go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right moving on to section number
five uh this is all about uh ethics
crucial ethics lessons to keep you out
of trouble
okay
so the first one is number 25 which is
transparency builds trust i really
believe this you can lose your
reputation really quickly in business
and in life
but if you're fully transparent uh then
this will this will help your career a
lot
uh and what i mean by that is you always
list the risks with with like remember
we look through the uh the s ones for
facebook goldman et cetera whatever and
and there's a lot of risks you gotta be
transparent and list all the risks and
whenever you're selling something to
somebody else you gotta tell yourself i
feel comfortable selling this to my
parents because i would tell my parents
the risks as well so you gotta disclose
all risk and that that is abraham
lincoln right there honest abe
uh and he was very very transparent as
well and apparently a very good man yeah
so that's that's honest honest abe uh or
as wayne and garth and wayne's world
referred him as babraham lincoln
i don't know what that means
but anyway uh transparency builds trust
remember that always disclose risks um
and the most important risk within the
first within the first couple minutes of
pitching any idea
uh or or uh product or service or
whatever it is or if you're trying to
raise money
because it'll make you come across as
being you know more ethical too and you
know what dude it might be a litigation
issue if you don't disclose them uh and
never sell a financial product or raise
money without getting a lawyer to write
your documents first because the lawyer
will make sure that you're you know the
risks are disclosed yeah transparency
builds trust
all right next up is don't trust this
type of person here
so
what am i talking about here well well
this type of person
is the type of person that backstabs
other people
and if
at work or at school or whatever
somebody is gossiping and we all will
enjoy gossip for whatever stupid reason
right otherwise don't watch tmz
um i'm a lawyer i don't know if you guys
watch the show but whatever uh but but
don't don't trust anybody that that
gossips
because and don't take part in yourself
uh because like around the water
fountain or water cooler at work
whatever
because those people that are
gossiping about others they'll gospel at
you as well
they will
and the worst type of person is the
person that cheats on their
spouse it's a sacred bond man
you know if they cheat on their spouse
of course they're gonna cheat you cheat
you in business as well you can't trust
them
it's like somebody that backstabs their
spouse to
you of course you're going to backstab
you
about you to somebody else
you can't trust these people
you can't trust them so just just be
careful just be careful there's a shadow
yeah
all right so just don't trust that type
of person and don't get involved in
gossip either uh and on wall street
you know if if somebody
i knew somebody got fired years ago
because he told a client
what one of his other clients which is
fidelity big mutual fund what they own
or what they said in the meeting
whatever
um and so that that client
might be grateful at first they heard
that information but they don't trust
you it's just it's not worth it it's not
worth it yeah yeah yeah and
sir richard branson and he's he's he's a
he's amazing
and i've listened to his all his audio
books on audible
um he just oozes positivity and he sets
the corporate culture for the virgin
companies
which is why um if you fly virgin
atlantic or virgin america
all the uh the people that work on the
airline the pilots et cetera the
they're the attendants they're they're
all really really positive and upbeat
um you know unfortunately alaska
airlines bought uh virgin america
recently so maybe the culture will get
you know diluted whatever
but but i i mentioned sir richard
branson because
his parents if he ever backstabbed
anybody when he was a kid they would
make him stand up and look in the mirror
and they would say look at yourself
don't be that person
don't be that person that backstabs
others
and little quick little side note off
topic
i have a guy i used to work for or work
with i should say years ago
he's so well spoken
and i got and i met his parents at some
events
uh and and and i asked uh i asked his
parents i said
you know mike mike is so well spoken
he's a gentleman he's confident
how did he become that way
and in you know how did you raise him
and my kids were younger there so i was
asking
and they said well you know we one thing
we did
was we would make him stand up and read
to us
and
when he was reading to us we we made
sure he projected his voice
and he was comfortable you know thinking
on his feet and and standing and reading
uh because we we got him to do it so we
didn't just make him read in his room
and my mom made me mom and dad during
the summers when i was a kid they make
me read for one hour every day every day
in the summers which helped me out
tremendously and i do with my kids now
too except i add a sweetener i say
if you read within the first hour of
being awake
you can read you got to do it for 45
minutes
or if it's later on the day it's like an
hour
so i incentivize them you know yeah
readers are leaders yeah
yeah and actually also this guy mike the
way that he learned how to public speak
was i've never tried this but
they would make him put a pencil in his
mouth
and then speak
and then that would try to speak clearly
that way so yeah
all right moving on
next up
number 27 how to tell if somebody is
lying that's pinocchio there right
um
does that mean i'm a liar because i got
a big nose no it's aerodynamic though it
is like dude when i'm skiing because of
this
like like when i tuck like i go fast
like try to beat me in a bike race you
can't because this is the aerodynamic
side of it but i'm not a liar i'm not
pinocchio i just have a very very
aerodynamic nose okay all right
if i can't laugh myself who can i laugh
at that reminds me of a sting song
an english man in new york which i love
off of sting's album the dream of the
blue turtles and sting said
it takes a man to suffer ignorance and
smile be yourself no matter what they
say
i love it so how do you tell if
somebody's lying and i covered this
before i think so i'm going to go into
this really really quickly so when i
worked at a great big hedge fund
um
and uh
it was called citadel
uh and uh
ken griffin nice guy um he's the the
founder billionaire he actually just
bought the biggest house or the most
expensive house in american history
uh and i remember whenever i meet with
him i spent an hour and a half with him
or an hour actually a half hour with him
one day in his office
and we talked about video games for for
ages and i looked at his bookshelf
and whenever i used to go into
somebody's office that's really
successful
more successful than me which is all the
time i would look at what books they
have and i'd order them immediately
and the book that that ken had actually
ken griffin
was a damadorian book on finance which i
bought and i i have now
but when i was at citadel upper
management
uh they sent um
they sent 25-year fbi and cia veterans
uh to train us on how to tell somebody's
lying
so now i know how to lie now i'm scared
but this really helped us a lot because
at that time it was like oh five i think
there was a lot of there are a lot of
scandals on wall street ceos were lying
and there was a joke on wall street
which is how do you know if a ceo is
lying
when they move their lips
but but they trained us on how to tell
somebody's lying and it helped me a lot
actually then while i was investing and
now today a lot
i can tell usually
so the four criteria is false
and
you one data point is mega trend you
usually need two three or four of these
to be correct or at least two of them
right at least two
uh and everybody's a little different so
there are exceptions so number one if
somebody breaks eye contact uh when
they're talking about something
that means they're they're probably
lying
however
i break eye contact a lot like i look
down a lot it's just i've always been
like that i look down sometimes right um
maybe i come across as not being
confident i don't know just what i do
um but if somebody breaks eye contact
when answering a question
then they might be lying
yeah and sometimes when people blink a
lot
they might be lying and dude i see it on
tv all the time i see people lying on tv
all the time
especially athletes when they're asked
are they going to come back to the team
next year and do they want to come back
they break eye contact
sometimes they they ramble
um but you'll notice it you'll notice it
and watch when somebody is being um
being interviewed on television just
watch how they answer questions
you know if if they look away
only the only time they look away a lot
is when they're answering a question
about something they're lying about that
might be a lie all right so number one
is they they break eye contact
number two is if somebody rambles on and
on and on and on and on and on and on
and on kind of like i am right now
to a simple yes or no question you know
it's like a kid
you ask a kid did you did you did you
did you take the last cookie from the
cookie jar
no i didn't take a last quarter i mean i
can't even reach it i mean look how tall
it's it's high up there and then i don't
know where the ladder is it's over there
but you know what i mean with steps tool
i can't find it's right there by the way
but i yeah
so there's that so we talked about um
breaking eye contact we talked about
rambling
uh another one is if if somebody is
shaking their foot and you can look down
and see it sometimes when they're lying
um and and sometimes because they've had
too much caffeine which obviously means
they get a hall pass
but if somebody's shaking their foot a
lot whatever when they're answering a
question they could be lying and that's
what a lie detector test does remember
remember ben stiller and robert de niro
and meet the parents right so that's
anyway that's what they were testing
he was cia i think in that movie
yeah and there's there's one more oh
yeah yeah touching your face touching
your face yeah
so uh if if if you touch your face a lot
especially cover your mouth
um and you usually don't do that but you
do that when you're answering a question
you might be lying so
don't don't accept just one of those
four criteria as being
gospel that somebody's lying
but multiple two or more of them could
mean somebody is lying and speaking of
touching your face and going off script
again here
of course given the health crisis we've
all got these things um
but what i do with my uh my kids and
myself now is like and i went to my
doctor years ago actually and i asked
her i said why are you not sick all the
time and she says because i wash my
hands a lot and i never touch my face
and so for me i've been biting my nails
dude since i was born i i just i i do it
it's it's terrible
and my kids do it as well because monkey
see monkey do you know whatever
so what i did was i bought this stuff
here it's called pro bell
and um given the virus scare right now i
put this on my nails
and i put on my kid's nails as well
and it tastes awful right it's not
doesn't hurt yet but it just tastes
awful but anyway
a little off topic but interesting
nonetheless
so that's how you can tell if somebody
is lying yeah
all right next up is how to destroy your
career in 30 seconds or less
if you send an email or a text or or a
snapchat and those are forever
and you didn't think two or three times
about it before clicking the send button
you're done
you're done just just be careful just be
careful
and
i always know that emails are for life
and everything i say on the phone is for
life as well you know when i worked on
wall street they used to say
um just understand that
all your calls could be recorded by the
government the fbi whatever i was like
that's fine i'm never going to do
anything unethical anyway
but that's
you got to do that and sometimes they'll
say
this call is being recorded for for
quality assurances or whatever or if you
hear a beep in the background you're
being recorded and they tell you to and
it's totally bogus like when customer
service calls you or you call them to
get help and they're recording the call
really like try it with them
yeah can you help me oh by the way i'm
recording this call
what is that so a little off topic but
just be really careful with electronic
stuff email voicemail voice every it's
all it's all recorded man you know the
privacy died a decade or two ago you
know once we realized there's a death of
distance in privacy because the internet
okay next up
oh we're done here okay we're now done
uh with with with section number five
okay so
go to uh section five in your book uh
and and take three minutes
uh to to to go through as we've done
before
take take three minutes to go through
all the uh
all these boxes here and just type in
comments or notes or whatever
it's optional of course
on on on stuff you've learned here or
stuff you can apply to to enhance your
your career so you got three minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's move on to section number six now
so section number six is every battle is
won before it's been fought it's a
famous quote from sun tzu and the art of
war
and at the top there i wrote crucial
battle preparation lessons and i've used
that quote before from sun tzu so i'll
go through this quickly
all right so number one
the first thing to talk about in section
number six is
over prepare for everything
if you over prepare for something like
really over prepare
you actually will enjoy it
when you're actually
doing what you prepared for
so like when you over prepare for a
speech which i've i've done many many
times before
i get to the speech and i'm so ready
i just kind of enjoy it man
i can't explain it it's like
this is out there but you remember when
you were younger and you studied really
hard for a math test like really really
hard and your friends asked you for help
and and you gave them help as well and
you know when one teaches to learn
but you you you studied a lot for it
and then when you get into the exam
it's so easy that you actually enjoy it
you know you're you're comfortable
you're confident you double check your
work as always of course
um but you enjoy it
you know the exam is your friend
you enjoy it because you over prepared
and what i do also is when i give a
speech quite often i bring two laptops
and what i used to do is i would bring
my laptop with powerpoint on whatever
years ago and i would be i would bring
uh those overhead slide things as well
just in case just in case it broke down
and when management at goldman sachs saw
me do that like oh my gosh that's
amazing i have confidence in this kit
and when i give a speech at my brother's
wedding back in 0-4 i did the same thing
i had backups just in case just in case
yeah
so over prepare for for everything
please and
you know whenever when i used to
interview other companies
i prepare more than anybody like i
recorded myself answering over 100
questions i video recorded myself too
did i sound too monotone did i sound too
arrogant
did i pause enough
did i use frameworks to tie together my
logic when i was lost in terms of moving
on to the bottom line is
and so if you over prepare for
everything
then
you'll actually enjoy the event when it
occurs
because quite often life all comes down
to a few short moments
the crucial speech or a test or whatever
it is
so over prepare
you know
like i i i know that i work harder than
anybody and i think it's because when i
was younger they they thought i had a
learning disability and they want to
fail me in the sixth grade in the eighth
grade and screw them whatever
not my my not my parents my teachers
uh and so i i kind of grew up insecure
and i over prepared for everything and
i'm so grateful to god that they kind of
misdiagnosed me or whatever it was they
tried to
destroy my confidence
i'm grateful to god it happened because
i over prepare for everything now
because of it
and there's a great book by malcolm
globwell called um
david and goliath
and it's about how people that have been
told their whole lives that they're not
good enough
are the ones that ultimately
do stuff that's important
so if if people have told you your whole
life or when you were younger and if
your confidence is lower than it should
be
just
be grateful that whatever happens within
reason obviously
whatever happened happened because your
secret weapon is you're going to work
your ass off work harder than anybody
else
and i've always worked harder than
anybody and i keep pushing the goal post
out and challenging myself and i think a
lot of it stems to you know it's it's
it's
nurture and nature
you know and you look at your kids why
are they successful or not or whatever
who cares
i mean success should be what they think
of themselves right you want to raise
confidence kids but you you know
somebody is
reaches their full potential in life
because of nurture or nature
so for for me part of it is nature it's
part of everybody but it's nurture
always you know being told when i was
younger you can't do it you can't do you
can't do it or elon musk poor guy in
south africa he got the crap kicked out
of him a lot growing up
or steven spielberg
you know been you know being
diagnosed with with um
with with uh
i think it was a dyslexia i can't
remember yeah
um and and he didn't get into usc film
school he didn't get in which is the
best film school so chip on his shoulder
which is great just great i'm sure i'm
sure there's more to it than that
but but sometimes i feel like if i hire
people from from harvard business school
they're going to be entitled as hell
and a lot of times like i'll i'll
lecture
at
a lot of schools and there's one in
particular in the bay area
that i hate lecturing at now
because
there is insane entitlement and
arrogance from a lot of the students
i'm not going to name that school
but my favorite school in the bay area
is san francisco state i love those kids
of death love no death i've hired them
i'll continue to hire them they're the
best
a lot of them are wealthy but a lot are
not and a lot are not entitled the worst
thing possible is hiring somebody that's
entitled
you know it's like like they start and
they're like i don't have to sweep the
floor it's like oh here's a broom let me
teach you
over prepare for everything
all right i love hiring people that are
poor smart and hungry
number 30 is the ohair test pass it and
watch your career take off
so the o'hare
test is the chicago o'hare airport
is a big airport that's one of the
biggest ones
and
quite and i've spent a lot of time there
like eight hours waiting in between
flights and
quite often with somebody else at work
you know someone more senior than me
whatever
and
did they enjoy my company and vice versa
in that eight hour layover the o hair
test it's important relationships are
more important than product knowledge
let me move
on all right oh i got this one from my
dad
my dad said chichi
never take a short that's my nickname
growing up chichi
never take a shortcut you've never taken
before when you're in a hurry i
completely believe that and you've all
been through that too i know every
single one of you have
you're late for something you're driving
whatever you're like oh i got to cut a
corner you know i got let me take a
shortcut i've never taken before and
you're even later than if you've gone
the regular routes
there's no shortcuts in life so i think
that's important to keep in mind
all right so we are now done uh with
section number six
okay and so as always we're going to do
next is we're going to do an exercise
go to
the cover page here if you want
and click on number six or you can do it
up here i always love to have multiple
ways to access stuff
and spend three minutes uh writing down
notes here uh in in all the lessons
uh for uh for section six
on
using the stuff you've learned this
lesson to help to enhance your career
so you got three minutes to do this go
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
moving on to section number seven you
can hear me using my transition words
here
okay so uh
goal setting okay follow these crucial
steps and achieve your dreams and see if
you guys can tell me what trophy that's
from
trying to be global here
okay so the first lesson here that's
number 32 is run to your fears
whatever you're most scared of in life
i want you to run to those fears
because i promise you
your competition is probably just as
scared they just don't say it
so whatever you're most fearful of in
business or in life in general run
towards it if you're scared of
accounting
condition yourself to enjoy it learn it
better in your competition have fun with
it too and always question why things
are called what they're called like we
talked before
about understanding math like we we
talked about the the banana i ain't
falling for no banana the tailpipe we
talked about the banana on the
denominator
we talked about the balance sheet it's
got a balance so just understand stuff
and condition yourself to understand
stuff and enjoy stuff that you're
fearful of
meaning accounting or whatever it is if
it scares you it scares your competition
just as much i promise you
so understand it and condition yourself
to enjoy it maybe
i don't know maybe like when you're
learning accounting wherever it is get
yourself a nice cup of coffee and listen
nice classical music in the backgrounds
um
you know and if you're having uh
problems doing that then remember when
you're younger and you went to the
library you remember the exact table you
sat at
deep in the stacks downstairs in that
corner
and you had your your music on and
coffee go back there recreate that
environment
okay
so run to your fears brenda your fears
and i put a shark tank there on purpose
uh and and if you're absolutely
terrified of sharks
why not try that and i found this
picture here i actually got on adobe i i
subscribe to a service where i get
images
so um there's actually it's actually a
cage you can do with a bunch of others
right so um
a little bit scary for me but i want to
get the point across and never have you
forget it run to your fears if you're
scared of public speaking
put yourself out there man
move to open spaces make yourself do it
run to your fears conquer your fear
because you'll never reach your full
potential in life unless you conquer
your fears
all right next up is uh make a gap
analysis and so
i i love this analogy here
um of of the mountain
so if your goal
is to accomplish something so big and
we'll just say it's the top of the
mountain
then i want you to visualize success
and just think about
what do you need to do to fill that gap
between where you are now and the top of
the mountain okay so make a very basic
gap analysis as part of your
goal-setting strategy
okay now lesson number 34 is
yale university's fascinating goal
setting study okay and some people say
this is an urban legend or myth i don't
care i want to talk about it anyway
so in 1950
yale university which is in the
northeast of the united states yale
university what they did in 1950 was
they asked their their graduating class
how many of you have written down your
goals
and three percent said
i have written down my goals
then 20 years later they went back to
the same graduating class in 1970
and they calculated the net worth
of everybody that graduated 1950 20
years later
and the net worth of the three percent
that had written down their goals
was greater than the other 97 combined
it's pretty amazing pretty amazing so
don't forget to write down your goals
and i used to carry my goals everywhere
with me they're now on my my iphone in
my calendar they repeat daily but what i
used to do was i would print out i would
buy those remember those those business
cards you can make yourself you put in
your printer and you pop them out and
they look awful whatever
i would get those
and then i would use powerpoint i
remember and just kind of write down
type my goals on the back in front of 10
cards and carry them around with me
everywhere and when i was down and out
i'd read through them
and i'm humbled to say i've accomplished
pretty much every goal
um one of the exceptions is uh
not getting a black belt in karate but
i'm a mean yellow belt yeah
all right uh next up is number 35 should
you get a graduate degree so you go to
university
um i i would say that if you network a
lot
and you still can't get
that career change
like if you set up literally a hundred
networking meetings
i found this
that's i don't know that's siri talking
again sorry put her aside it's a daily
event
right
so
uh if you set up a hundred networking
meetings and you still can't change
careers
then consider getting your graduate
degree
that's what i would say that's what i
would say yeah uh and you might say
chris 100 is a little extreme
well dude getting a graduate degree at
university it can cost a hundred grand
including lost wages etc
100 grand
so that means that a thousand or 100
meetings
that's like a thousand dollars each
meeting i'm saving you
so again do a hundred meetings i know it
sounds like a lot and when i say 100 it
probably means you'll do 30. and you'll
still get what you want because you did
30.
like james cameron said set your goals
so high that if you fail you still fail
above everyone else's expectations
it's kind of like we did cryptocurrency
stuff i didn't really expect you guys to
do all 49 steps
but if you do a lot of them that's
that's better than just one or two or
not right
okay and what you can also do is if you
try your best to network to make that
career change and you can't
then um
go to linkedin and find people that have
done it and look at their blueprints do
they have graduate degrees what have
they done to get there
but i guarantee you i almost guarantee
you if you network like crazy you can
you get pretty much where you want in
life
obviously there's exceptions if you want
to be a doctor
you know
you have to go to medical school
although i'm on the board of a charity
i'm really proud of called doctors
without diplomas yeah
that's not true yeah
okay number number 36 i love this one
push the goal post out
um
once you achieve your goals
what you got to do is you got to you
gotta you gotta push the goal post out
you you gotta set new goals always
because sometimes when you achieve your
goals
you get a little bit depressed
i know it's weird like at first you're
like hey i did it you're like
dude now what
got to keep pushing the goal post out
keep challenging yourself
uh and if you get a chance i want you to
please go and do a search on matthew
mcconaughey's best oscar speech from
things 2014 or maybe a little bit before
that i don't remember
but he talks about
competing with himself
and challenging himself and it was
amazing oscar speech i love it to death
because he was so real
he didn't give a damn what people
thought about him he was talking to his
dad up in heaven
and he was saying
dad i love you
i know you're up there
in your underpants probably
with lemon pie
with a can of miller light and you're
dancing
he didn't care then he talked about
challenging himself so watch that that
speech if you get a chance it's pretty
powerful
that's right from his heart
you know and as maya angelou said
people might not remember what you said
but they'll never forget the way you
made them feel i really believe that and
when i get my explain you how to give a
great speech
um which you have to learn thoroughly um
if you're gonna write a business plan
because when you write a business plan
and you present it to potential
investors
you got to inspire them as well
and i'm going to teach you you know how
to give a presentation
um like uh like matthew mcconaughey did
and i think he got the award for dallas
buyer's club or some movie back then yet
all right so we are now done with
section number seven which is which is
goal setting
so as always i want you to please go
to your workbook
and then i want you to go to section
seven
and then spend um it's working
sometimes that's double click yeah uh
and then just spend uh spend three
minutes uh going through um all the
lessons here
and document how you can apply some of
the stuff you've learned to enhance your
career and what you can always do of
course is is for homework
if you want it's all optional
is you can read through the chapters
here and so i provide you this is half
the book today and next class i'll
provide you with the other half of the
book in next classes uh workbook
as well and i thought about giving you
the actual book and i said no way man i
want it this way so you you at least
have the option to write down notes
because one little note you take in
these boxes can change your life
yeah you can have a breakthrough
personal breakthrough yeah
all right so
take uh three minutes to do that now go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
moving on to section number eight
this is a great one
so section number eight is simply called
happiness is and i want to spell that
h-a-p-p-y
n-e-s-s there's a famous movie where
they spell happiness with a y what movie
was that you should have all seen it by
now
if not rent it's got my favorite actor
in it ever will smith yeah
uh and and if you didn't
you're probably younger than me i'm an
old man but if you didn't watch the
fresh prince of bel-air ever watch it on
netflix or online it's great and we'll
we'll suppose the best i love that guy
he's so inspirational too he's amazing
he's amazing
so um section number eight i wrote the
top there it's crucial that you find an
occupation you love and you'll never
work a day in your life of course that's
of course that's a very famous quote
from confucius
all right number 37 here is
don't have a job instead have a passion
and be happy and achieve all your
business goals and if you get up in the
morning and you tell yourself i'm going
to work with all due respect you're
doing it wrong
you you got to find your your your
purpose your passion you know what was
the reason that that
you were put on this earth
so so find your passion
and once you do as confucius said you'll
never work a day for the rest of your
life and
it's like having a new baby you know
when you have your first baby
some of you might know
[Music]
you unlock a level of happiness you
never thought you could feel in your
life
well when you get up every day and do
what you love doing
it's the same feelings that not as good
but a little bit you know a little bit
of that uh lightning in a bottle you
feel it
feel it inside here
um that's that's that's pure happiness
pure joy pure adrenaline
uh pure euphoria when you do what you
love doing and it might take you a while
you know sometimes it might take to your
60s figure it out took me to my 40s
and i'm 73 now so um yeah
all right moving on number uh oh guys
laugh your failures watch this video
dude that i love the internet was made
just for that
i love that video it's hysterical and
whenever you think about your failures i
want to condition you to laugh at your
failures you'll find humor in it you
know to a certain extent
um
yeah anyway so i i i look at my failures
in life and i laugh at them they're fun
they're funny i don't know
so
condition yourself to kind of laugh your
failures and you won't take life too
seriously you'll live longer you'll be
happier
and you'll be willing to fail again so
you can laugh again
all right next up is uh money does not
equal uh happiness yeah
so i i i had a trip to um mumbai
uh business trip years ago i think it
was
halt international school of business
wanted me to give a speech or a couple
speeches so i did it there in up in
delhi as well
and that trip changed me man
it changed me because when we drove from
the airport to the four seasons in
mumbai whatever and mumbai's there's 25
million people
tons of rich people there but there's
also a large number of people that that
live in the slums
and we were stuck in traffic thank god
because it was right by the slums and
i've never seen so many people with
nothing
so happy
they were so happy
it's kind of like when um i remember
matthew my youngest kid
we used to go to the park on sundays
and
there was always a large group
of
people from
immigrants
and they would sit on they had nothing
like we had a nice blanket to sit on
they had cardboard boxes and they would
barbecue
and there was tons of them
together in a family
you know a bond of love
and my son matthew he was like four of
them he said daddy why
why do they always seem so much happier
than everybody else
they got nothing to lose you know you
want to buy experiences not things
and then you go to an expensive
restaurant look around dude when you go
to expensive restaurant look around
you see all these arrogant people
whatever and i like going at good
restaurants whatever but they're not as
happy as when you go to a park
you know it's sometimes i feel like like
david geffen
he's a billionaire and
no high school degree started in the
mail room and he uh
he started guffing records he signed
guns or roses and
other bands whatever
um and then he's one third of dreamworks
as well along with katzenbergen and
spielberg but but david geffen said
for those of you that think that money
can buy you happiness you don't have
money
it's it does not buy happiness at all i
promise you and and i remember uh when i
worked at goldman
every christmas you get you got a bonus
everyone was so damn depressed every
christmas
because the cancer of wall street
and western society is you always
compare yourselves to those that have
more you know when you look into the
bowl of your neighbor
you shouldn't look to see if you have
more
you you should look to see if if he or
she has enough or at least as much as
you do
yeah
so money no matter what you think
does not buy happiness of course we need
to make a certain amount to live
but
don't make money your god
you know it's it's one of the ten
commandments not to do something like
that so um
yeah so anyway
and there's there's a great british
airways commercial
that that i want to share with you soon
um
that was filmed in new york in india
that really touched my heart
and really makes you focus on family and
what real happiness is
[Music]
my name is ratnesh
[Music]
i'm originally from mumbai
[Music]
i mean i like to call it bombay because
i grew up there
[Music]
what do i remember from bombay
well
playing in the streets
taking the local
jasmine gajra's in the flower market
and
my mother praying in the morning
you can move thousands of miles away
but these images
they are always with you
[Applause]
[Music]
i am alka my full name is
i am 61 years old
my son is ratnesh he's staying in new
york
first when he told me he wanted to go to
the u.s i felt very excited but when the
moment came when he was leaving india
that time i was really very nervous and
quite heartbroken i must say
[Music]
today british airways has given me a
seat on a plane
it is for my son's favorite dish okra
paratha
they will fly to america
and surprise him in his apartment
i think this will make him come home and
visit his mummy
i like every mother does i used to
experiment with different things putting
in his different box
most of the time the other vegetables
they will return from the school
untouched
but whenever i am giving okra it is
finished
i asked him why you like okra the most
he said mama
my teacher has told the child who eats
okra becomes best in his mathematics
my son is progressing day by day
his dreams are getting fulfilled
and his happiness is more than what i
ever want for him
when he will look at the tiffin box
first he will think from where has it
come but once he tastes the food he will
know it is made by his mummy
and i am sure he will start searching
for me in his apartment
i miss him so much because when he left
home he was hardly 17 years old
and from that day
he did not return home
i miss myself
[Music]
my mom had cooked my favorite meal
and she was waiting for someone from
british areas to pick up the different
carrier
so they sent me
after flying from new york to mumbai
there i was
walking to her door
smelling her cooking
it was an incredible feeling
sometimes even when you know what's
going to happen
you cannot even imagine how it's going
to be
i got the opportunity to see my mother
in a way had never seen her before
she looked lonely
she looked like she sounds over the
phone i just wanted to run out and give
her a hug
[Music]
mommy
i'm here
oh
[Music]
it was a great moment
it was a family moment even his dad was
there
we are three of us sad we talked
and
i didn't ask him when are you leaving i
said i will not ask you today
let this question be for tomorrow
[Music]
what a great commercial man
um
just appreciate what you have that's
what happiness is
not hoping
to get something later that will make
you happier thing-wise
but
happiness is just
appreciating what you have
that's what it is
and i believe that if you're happy and
if this works
this will work much much better
you'll come full circle
okay next up is all your wealth can't
buy you health it's so true
um and
that that's a quote i think from i think
i got it from bob dylan yeah all your
wealth can't buy your health
uh and there's a great book by the the
dalai lama that i mentioned before
i read it on my honeymoon and when i was
in indonesia which is a great setting
and
read his book if you haven't yet but but
he says basically that
the problem with western society is we
sacrifice
our health our entire lives in order to
make money
then at the end of our lives we
sacrifice all of our money to maintain
our health
and then we look back
and we realize
we never really lived to begin with
so treasure every single day
every day
smell the roses along the way i used to
tell myself years ago when i was in my
20s i was like i don't get married have
kids until i make my fortune in my
empire dude
what's the point
start a family now enjoy life today
don't live for tomorrow
live for today
number 42 is when to change careers
and
i hate to end this on a down note but i
have to in order to make a big impact
like i mentioned before if you get out
of bed in the morning
and you're not happy
and you feel some sort of depression
related to your job
channel that frustration and that
unhappiness
network like crazy
channel that frustration
and find something you love doing
you know don't only focus on money i get
it we have to pay bills i get it but
enough's enough dude
like at some point you got to realize
that
what am i here for
why don't i laugh as much as i used to
when i was younger
why am i working in a big company i'm
not being myself
when i was younger i used to laugh so
hard until i fell down with my buddies
and it hurt in a good way
why am i not laughing anymore
why am i not being myself
why do i get up every day and go to a
job i can't stand working for people i
don't respect
and i don't respect myself as much
anymore because i'm not being myself
either i'm being political at work i'm
not being me
i just want to be me
so if you're depressed
and if you don't see work
as something you enjoy
don't do it
you know don't try to live somebody
else's life or or or be a prisoner in
someone else's mind and do stuff to make
them happy
like if people in your life want you to
be a lawyer or doctor whatever it is
and you're not passionate about wanting
to be a lawyer meaning you don't want to
be a liar
and you're not passionate about
being a doctor because you want to be
around blood and stuff if that's not
i mean it's great to help people
and i respect you know all doctors
and um
civil rights lawyers only
but
you got to do it what drives you makes
you happy because i really do believe
that if you
if you do something you love doing in
life you find the why of your life
then you'll
not only be good at it
but the money will come accidentally
you won't
i mean i i go to a basketball game or a
football game or whatever
and all these dudes on the field
they don't get up in the morning and say
oh god i gotta go play a game today
that's not work man that's awesome
same thing with rock and roll star
you know they don't get up in the
morning oh god i gotta play another gig
today
it's a beautiful thing to be an artist
because you get to express yourself
which is why also like i think of what i
do and what we all do as as being art
you know the the palette for us is a
powerpoint document or an excel
spreadsheet that we can we can jazz up
with cool buttons and colors and fun
stuff
it's artistic and it's fun for me and
for you as well
but
you got to do something you love doing
in life
and you got to take risks as well and
start your own companies on the side
and in semesters three and four we'll
you'll you'll write a kick-ass business
plan and i'll help you
kind of define what
it might look like in the future for you
but
the worst thing can happen to you is
you're
you wake up one day and you're way older
than you are now
and
you're working for this jerk
that pays you
this much money
to make their dreams become a reality
you got to take chance to take risks
if you're not happy doing what you're
doing either
change your line of work by networking a
lot or do a ton of side hustles on the
side
until you find something you're
passionate about you know and that's
kind of what i did too i i was working
venture capital
i wasn't happy i loved teaching
and my side hustle was was teaching and
then also putting stuff online like this
um
i didn't do it for the money
i did it because i wanted to help like i
want to help those those kids at the
limo foundation that was fun for me
helping
it gave me a sense of purpose my why as
well
so if you get up in the morning and you
tell yourself you're going to work then
you got to find a different career path
and start networking a lot to meet with
people that work in different industries
or just figure out what is the reason
you're putting on this earth what makes
you happy you want to make video games
make video games
you want to make movies make movies
you want to you want to teach online
teach online today you want to be a
writer write that book
jk rowling got rejected 30 times
i want you to fail fast and fail often
and i want to liberate your fear of
failure
we are now done
with section number eight
so what i want you to do is i want you
to go
and do the exact same exercise i just
mentioned you
go go to number eight so you can go to
the cover page if you want there's
milling ways to get there
click here
please work
is it working
it is working sorry
it works easier in the word version and
pdf as well yeah and i want you to go
through all these lessons here and just
type up notes
uh on did i screw that up
dude i screwed that up we're not gonna
edit this i wanna show you how to
correct that so i clicked on here watch
what happens it went to number eight so
i gotta change that so edit link
and what i'll do here is i'll click here
it should be fine in the uh
go to headings
number
number eight
happiness is
a warm gun that was a great song by the
beatles and the white album
so is number nine
the same album okay here so click here
and you go down there
uh and yeah i want you to just just
complete this you like the little smiley
face there it took me a while to do but
i had a dude i had a smile on my face
making that too if you're ever like kind
of bummed out not in a great mood
get this is crazy but it works
get a piece of paper and a pencil and
draw a smiley face and i guarantee you
as you're drawing the happy face part of
it you'll
you'll start to smile
all right um yeah so take a couple
minutes three minutes here and just
write down here uh you know things that
you've learned in this class that that
you can apply to make your your enhance
your career or make you get closer to
reaching your full potential so you got
three minutes to do this go
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back
so
in addition to writing the quiz
uh today uh and try to complete the quiz
within seven days please as always but
in addition to writing the quiz what i
want you to do for homework today is i
want you to use the contents of many or
all of the 42 lessons that you
documented today
in your workbook and i want you to apply
them to your daily schedule templates
so
we all know it looks like this
and i hope you guys are doing this daily
at least during the workdays weekdays i
promise you it helps you be more
productive okay and you can customize
this too but what i want you to do is
again i want you to take
everything you wrote down the 42 steps
okay and and if you want for homework
you can
meditate more on the 42 steps or read my
version of each chapter in your 58-page
workbook whatever it is
but i want you to take what you wrote
down and i want you to apply it to your
daily template somehow if you want to if
there's
a couple things you wrote down which are
so money and so awesome for your career
and increase your happiness way to
increase your happiness i want you to
put it on here either write it down
daily on this
or what you can do is you can customize
this and let me just remind you really
quickly how to do this okay
so what i want you to do is go to
haroonventures.compg1-1-1
so remember the three once not two three
all lowercase i'll go there with you
let's do it
all right uh oh before we go there what
time is it it's oh it's it's four
o'clock the sun is setting at seven p.m
new york time
i want to show you
okay so let's go here remember i set it
at sundown um it's probably a nice way
to end this
aha look here
it now says checkout will be available
at uh 8 30 p.m saturday night uh in 25
hours and 29 minutes thank you for your
purchase while we observe our shabbat
okay cool
that's awesome that's awesome yeah and
there's it's unbelievable this company
they kick ass and they don't have a
competitive disadvantage for taking that
one day off a week but but it's amazing
so if i wanted to check out look this is
pretty cool so if i wanted to check out
it won't let me
see here
uh be back soon it says so um anyway
it's pretty cool but it's kind of a nice
note to end this lecture on anyway
um you got to take your breaks one day
off a week all right let me close that i
almost forget what i was talking about
but i don't
what we're gonna do is we're going to go
together
to
haroun
ventures
slash all lower case
e-1-1-1 you need three ones not two
three okay this is the first thing we
did uh uh it's it's or pg i'm such a
[ __ ]
pg-1-1-1 okay
the very first personal growth class
class one semester one topic one okay
remember that from a while back
all right remember this
so what i want you to do is for homework
i want you to take what you wrote in
your notebook
all 42 things
or less if you wrote fewer than 42 it's
fewer yeah
and i want you to customize this
so that um you could apply a lot of
those things to your daily templates
okay
so if you click here you can go to the
powerpoint version
and you can go back and watch the first
class over again if you want to
for a refresher on how to do all this
but i'll show you really quickly now
yeah so what you can do is if you have
the powerpoint version downloaded you
can you can change this around uh if you
want to okay
so
um you'll notice that not all the fields
can be changed so what you can do if you
want to change it you can go to view
then you go to slide master
and you can change the stuff here so
let's just say that
one of the uh the things you wrote down
was i don't know
let's think about this
maybe it was to oh schedule time with
family spend more time with family
so what you can do is if you wanted to
you can do what i do which is what i do
down here uh you you can right here just
hard coded in here so it's here every
day
right here
you can go here and type in schedule
time with family
time with family
or or go to the gym every day hard-coded
in here so it's always here
i don't know
gym time
that sort of thing or whatever 42
lessons you learned and you can even
change this around too you're like you
know what chris i don't even use this
part of it so let me just highlight all
this this stuff here and
let me get rid of actually just these
ones here let me get rid of this
and you could say did you go to the gym
i don't know jim
question mark and then you can change it
so you you fill an x in here or whatever
it is or get rid of this entirely and
just i don't know write write down your
your goals here completely so click here
get rid of these bad dudes here these
dudes here i should say
and then just write down some of your
goals that you want to appear here daily
goals to be here
daily
from the 42 lessons or whatever it was
you you typed stuff you want to keep in
mind remember here you can change all
this stuff and i wrote this in tiny blue
writing why did i write that again i'm
sure it's my moronic sense of humor
i wrote here sorry to make you zoom in
this much but i never want you to forget
this
if you want to get something done give
it to a busy person the more you
schedule the more you will do the more
you will get done as well also if you
write down your goals almost every
single day then watch out because you
will accomplish them all tell people
about your goals and set deadline dates
thanks chris with a immature smiley face
so anyway you could you can go through
this if you want to and
if you want you can actually get the pdf
version here uh and and if you have a
pdf writer you can download this and
change it around if you want to using a
pdf writer i'll let you figure out how
to do that as well
so do that for homework do that for
homework please
and take your time with it and enjoy the
exercise as well please okay great
all right um
i already showed you how to do it okay
good
great um we are now done with uh with
today's class thank you
welcome to entrepreneurship 1-3 that's
semester one class number three as
always please make sure that you have
the appropriate workbook open as you can
see on the screen here
in either pdf format word format
or google docs format very important you
have at least one of these open today or
one of them because there's going to be
a lot of exercises kind of like what we
did last class and so we're going to do
the second half of the this book here
today it's going to be plenty of
exercises now you're probably thinking
chris what is going on why do you have
this thing up here
uh well i want to do something a little
bit different today before we we jumped
right in on it um
when i was a kid
i remember laughing so hard until it
hurt
and
with my friends you know what i'm
talking about like yeah sometimes you're
rolling on the ground laughing so hard
and then what happens is you
i don't know you kind of grow up and you
you stop laughing as much and you start
working for other people
and you're just not yourself anymore
and and
this really hit home for me because this
here is um
this is a a chair
from uh exhibition stadium uh which is a
a great stadium that no longer exists in
toronto
and it was for the the blue jays
actually the toronto blue jays my
baseball team i'm so passionate about
sports
and you can see i've got a big ticket up
there as well for the first game in
1977. tickets were really really big
back then but now people are
environmentally environmentally friendly
dad here we know i promise
but the one thing that my dad my brother
my family and i my sisters my mom and we
all have in common is a love of baseball
and love of sports uh love of the
toronto blue jays uh i'm feeling
homesick just thinking about it uh and
so i bought this uh it wasn't that
expensive it's it's it's old it's rusty
as you can tell i bought this on on ebay
and get anything on ebay
and it reminds me of the great times i
had with my dad my my my family going to
to games growing up and you know when i
was a kid i didn't i didn't realize that
baseball was a business or sports was a
business and that's why it meant like i
still love sports i still love baseball
and the blue jays especially
but um
it meant a lot more to me when i was
younger yeah and i just want to cherish
these memories and you know sometimes
when i um
when i'm not in the best of moods or i'm
kind of upset or depressed a bit which
happens
um i i think about when i was younger
and when i laughed really hard until it
hurt give me one second i want to get
something here i got a
got a couple these props here um
this is a canadian money this is real
canadian money what we use there that's
i don't know why i picked that up sorry
i got a couple baseball cards um and
these meant the world to me when i was a
kid these are rookie cards for a couple
of great troll blue jays players
whatever
but this here
this here means a lot to me and
what happened and my kids like they have
a love of baseball as well um
and
i want you all to think about one point
in your life when you were so euphoric
so happy and i want you to meditate
about that really think about it
and i want that to be your trigger
for if you ever aren't in the best moods
you're not if you're not in the peak
peak mental state if you're not yourself
if you're not happy
i want you to remember when you were
younger maybe you were family at a game
or something bonding with your dad your
mom your brother sister whatever
your your spouse uh and that should
put you back in that peak mental state
we all have one or two incidents in our
life that we all remember that put us in
that peak mental state um and i wasn't
even planning on talking about this but
i'm gonna wing it this is um
well okay so
this here
um and if you can't see it properly um
then matt what i want you to do is match
my editor he's awesome get the 2016 tops
jose batista card uh number eight and
and this here was um
a game number of years ago uh and my
three boys and i'll show you what my
kids look like actually
um so these are my my three boys this is
um andrew um dylan a little munchkin uh
and he's usually not that quiet
and matthew and they're so different
they're like sons to me i love them to
death
but
i i bring this up because
what happened was we were watching a
baseball game it was 2015.
it was one of the happiest moments of my
life
after i got married and all that good
stuff in case christine's watching yeah
but we were watching the game here it
was in this house and we're upstairs and
we were losing the game to the texas
rangers another baseball team
and this guy named jose batista and this
is a a picture of of what happened
he hit the most
epic home run
and it was a come from behind victory
and then he flipped his bat
and we all like my three boys and me
they have a little brother me we all
jumped up and down up and down up and
down and we're yelling top of our lungs
we were so happy and they were jumping
into my arms and all that stuff and
i was
i was euphoric i was happy
and
whenever i'm not in the best moods i i
think of this situation here and by the
way this this baseball that he hits to
win that game uh i bid on it in an
auction i gotta open it right at the end
killed me but whatever it is what is um
but this is what i think of
this moment right here
and so um
and maybe this camera has got a better
angle i'm not sure with the lighting and
stuff uh but
but that's yeah this is uh
this means the world to me you know my
boys obviously my family and christine
like my parents everybody
and when i'm not in the best of moods uh
what i do
is um and give me one second put this
back here
make sure there's no
glare i don't think there is whoop okay
good glare scott nice when i'm running
out of the best of moods i i think of
this this event
and it gets me back into peak mental
state
you know um
you can snap out of a crappy mood
by
thinking of a trigger point in your life
at one point in your life when you were
you were so euphoric so happy
um and you know just because you're
older now doesn't mean you can't
love the same things that you loved when
you were a lot younger like you like
video games f it play video games
you know you love sports just don't
think of it like it's a business just
remember the times you bonded with
family and friends
over great sporting events and if you
can if you get a chance
you know if they tear down your stadium
that you used to go to whether it's a i
don't know cricket stadium rugby
baseball australian rules football or
whatever it is
see if you can buy that that seat yeah
so anyway um
think about a trigger point if you can't
in your life to get you in that peak
mental state if you ever need uh a
pick-me-up
okay
what i'll do now is i'll go into
high-speed and and i'll get this old
rustic uh piece of not junk out of the
way
all right
let's do this let's do this this will be
a fun class
so again this is uh
e1-3
unjustified criticism
is nothing more than a disguised
compliment so bring it on doubters and
i'm gonna have a bunch of brand new
quotes that you're gonna enjoy i hope
you enjoy them uh and so if if somebody
says something that that
dislodges you or gets you out of your
peak mental state
um
and it's so unjustified i want you do
one of two things
the first thing i want you to do is i
want you to tell yourself
they're probably very envious
for whatever reason
you know and that criticism i don't
choose to accept it
because it's unjustified but you know
what and this is me talking to the jerk
that criticized me or whoever it might
be in the future and you know who i'm
talking about this has all happened to
all of us you know what
i want to thank that jerk
because
he is so insecure
that he gave me a great compliment thank
you bring it on bring it on
and if you're not getting criticized
you're not successful enough it's gonna
happen and i want you to embrace it
because unjustified criticism is nothing
more than a disguised compliment think
about that
also think about um
that trigger point you have in your life
for me it's that jose batista
baseball home run thing that uh got my
kids and i in insanely great mood i gave
him shivers just just thinking about it
right now
so again we're gonna go through uh just
part two of of this book today uh and
there's gonna be plenty of exercises as
well and there's a reason why i have
this stuff here
and there's a reason why i have that
there as well and i've got things that
are really personal to me like i'm
opening up in this episode like this is
my most prized possession
um it was jamaica january of uh of 1980
and and my dad and i
um we went for a walk on the beach in
jamaica and i was uh i was seven at the
time and i remember really well
and
there was a
this was this was dark green when i saw
it initially there's tons of bamboo
uh that was on the ground uh and
somebody cut it up and my dad took it
and he got a keychain
uh and uh while i was swimming in the
pool uh my mom was back in the hotel
room because katie my little baby sister
wasn't feeling all that but my dad
actually carved in here and it says
chris jamaica
uh january 1980 i've used this as a pen
holder whatever i spilled yeah years ago
i don't remember when but um this means
a lot to me so i'm going to open up
today
um
yeah so anyway we're going to do part
two now of this book
yeah so again there's 17 sections in the
book
last class we talked talked about uh
sections one through eight
um and in this class we're gonna discuss
sections um nine through seventeen nine
through seventeen yeah
all right um so
just take notes uh in in today's
workbook please on
how you can apply
every single lesson we talk about as
many as you can
to help to enhance your life make you
happier
improve your career prospects help you
with goal settings et cetera
and so what i did was i made 101 places
for you to write down
uh these uh in in the workbook so
today's workbook we're going through
lessons 43 43 through 101
uh and in the last workbook uh we did uh
1 through 42. so if you haven't watched
the previous lecture please go back and
watch it first okay thank you
all right
let's talk about section number nine
which is called legal stuff is important
and so
lesson number 43 is how to protect your
family
it's really really important
if you ever start a company
or if
you're part of a partnership and you
have equity in a company
that if somebody gives you an employment
contract that you hire a lawyer to get
them to review it
the problem with lawyers is it doesn't
matter
if you really trust the person you're
working for
if they give you a contract to sign
they probably haven't read it their
lawyer made it and their lawyer is
obviously biased
uh and so i really want you to hire a
lawyer on the side to review the legal
document please do that please please
please
um and i've done that before when i've
been part of partnerships and it saved
my ass it really really did
what happened was there was a
stipulation
in the contract that if one of our
companies we invested in venture capital
companies got acquired
or had an exit
or there was a harvesting event meaning
it went public or whatever
that
there was no timeline when i would get
paid but i would get paid one day which
could have meant 50 million years from
now whatever so that that really saved
my backside uh and i actually ended up
selling all my positions whatever
um and
also when when when i've had other like
i in my hedge fund i had 25 of my hedge
fund um i actually had a i sold it to a
high net worth investor that was one of
my my big backers
uh and and i hired a lawyer as well and
the lawyer put in some language to just
to save my backside like all the people
in business i've dealt with they've been
ethical i trust them
but you gotta you gotta watch out uh and
the same thing when it comes to
if you start your own company
once you start generating some revenue
please make sure
that you talk to a lawyer i'm going to
get down my knees now because i want you
i want you to remember this forever can
i make a fool of myself laugh at me ouch
not with me hurts my knees now when i
kneel i'm getting older
please
please please please i'll look at all
three cameras actually please you you
and you
i want you all
to get a lawyer
to create
documents to register your company when
you start it okay when you start it once
you start figuring out that this is
something you want to do for us your
life or you're generating revenue that
sort of thing
it's really important because when you
start getting some success people will
come after you they'll sue you it's
happened to me having me recently
actually uh and and somebody went after
me because i've done well in one of my
companies
uh and um i i was gonna out litigate
them i was gonna be a pit bull and a
pork chop and finally they dropped the
lawsuit which was garbage anyway yeah
but thank god i was protected just in
case nothing happened to god but you
gotta prepare for the worst always
always always please please please
please
um so yeah protect your family protect
your family always and if it's kind of a
if you're not sure how to do it with
your your boss
if you're given
partnership or whatever in the company
and if it's a really really big company
as long as you don't have power
but um a lot of times you do and when
you approach your boss to talk about
this or whoever it is partner or
whatever just say look i have to i have
to be mindful of my family in case i get
hit by a bus or whatever i want to make
sure taken care of
and anybody with half a heart or half a
brain will understand and sympathize
with you as well okay
all right uh next up is um always
always always
ask
a lawyer for help
if
you're not sure
if an investment opportunity is
legitimate
okay so
if you don't get an investor uh offering
memorandum or an s1 document or whatever
it might be if you can't get access to
that
or if it looks like it's half-assed
and
i want you to get your lawyer to look at
that first okay or at least seek their
counsel and never invest in anything
without legal documents anyway like an
offering memorandum and we've talked a
lot about how to read them how to read
the s ones for example
so make sure you have access that and
don't ever do a big investment yourself
without getting your lawyer to review
the documents anyway just in case
just in case okay so just
always be careful and that's one of the
very few lawyers i love which is um
gandhi i think he's a lawyer right i
think so yeah okay
all right next up staying out of trouble
uh in this digital reality we all know
this that everything is recorded
everything every email is recorded
every snapchat that's right be careful
that every snapchat every tick tock or
whatever video
the video does your platform is
every single one is recorded
every phone call is well
everything
so
obviously not anything unethical but
just be careful just be careful things
can be taken out of context always
always always
in every message that i write
in everything i say on every phone call
i've always been
very careful in case somebody takes it
out of context
always be careful
if you feel like you're being trapped
with an email
don't respond
don't respond
be careful
everything is recorded and when i worked
on wall street
every now and then i'd hear a beep in
the background and that meant that the
call is being recorded by law they had
to do that
and i know for a fact actually i think i
know
that a lot of my calls were recorded by
the fbi
and the sec
i never got caught for anything i never
did anything wrong
but just in case be careful
and i was told actually at a couple
hedge funds i worked at that just
pretend every call is recorded just be
careful
just be careful it's never worth it
cutting corners anyway
it's never worth it never worth it
there's so many celebrities that have
gone to jail
for years
for something as stupid as a buddy
calling said hey i got a stock pick for
you okay thanks okay i'll buy it
whatever
they heard something like martha stewart
etc just be careful okay
assume everything is documented
every every single phone call email etc
i know it sounds a little silly for me
to go on and on and on about this but i
care i care yeah
and if a lawsuit ever does occur
what's going to happen is lawyers will
go through email servers um texts
whatever and they'll find they can find
something like i believe warren buffett
said this if you ever investigate
somebody enough you'll find something
you'll find something
so just be careful yeah
all right next up is i want you to
please go to your workbook
uh and similar to what we did last class
open today's workbook
and i want you to click on the the
number nine
on the cover um
meaning section nine on the front page
click on the number nine there yeah and
and if the if it doesn't work for some
reason at the top it says section nine
you can click on the hyperlink there as
well
um then i want you to spend three
minutes please
writing down notes on how you can apply
the lessons in section nine to enhance
your career you have three minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back
section number 10
management best practices
the most crucial business revelation is
that ideas are commodities execution is
not it's all about the management team
most people don't realize that most
people think if i have a solid business
model
then everybody will invest and things
will work out that's not the way the
world works
so let's go through these
so lesson number 46 is you want to
praise in public and criticize in
private and this is a great way to
manage people
and i actually got this this idea here
from the former ceo
of a great software company called
splunk splk is the ticker
and godfrey sullivan was the former ceo
of the company and i also invested in
him
when he was the ceo of a great software
company called hyperion that oracle
bought and before that godfrey worked at
apple he has a lot of great experience
and so i'm trying to impress upon the
importance of looking at a great
management team first before investing
now godfrey said one day to me um you
know i asked why are you so successful
and people will do that man it's great
and that's the crux of my whole book
people will do that if you see somebody
successful
um get more successful than you are
right now right now
then i want you to approach them and ask
them for you know just advice ask them
what give me one reason why you're
successful and people love talking about
themselves look at me i i i won't stop
talking i keep talking about myself it's
annoying really
uh but i'm not successful
uh but
so yeah i've met with a ton of people
that are way more successful ever be and
i always ask them for one piece of
advice that's not taught in schools
and that's why i do what i do right now
i'm trying to teach you real practical
based stuff
uh and not theoretical crap
and so godfrey said he likes to praise
in public and only criticize in private
you know there's nothing worse than
being criticized by your boss in front
of many of your i don't know fellow
workmates
um it destroys morale and it makes you
makes you hate your job
so nobody wins
if you're going to critic criticize
somebody uh try to do it in private
always always always and there's right
ways to criticize tim
you know um and there's
i hate to do this uh but i think i'll
talk about it right now um
and i'm gonna tell you about how to
hire and fire people later but
today but when you let somebody go
that what you're supposed to do is this
and they usually know it's coming
you sit down with them and you start off
by and usually do it on a monday if you
want to ruin their weekend
you you start off by saying something
very complimentary
but sincere and real
like everybody on the team
really enjoys your company and you did a
great job on the project x or whatever
it is
however
due to this this and this i'm so sorry
we have to let you go
so you always start with with something
positive and that's extreme because i'm
talking about letting somebody go and
i'll give you more information on how to
do that very very soon
but when you're criticizing somebody uh
that you want to keep
um you want to start off and be
complimentary at first yeah yeah it's
more subtle that way and it'll take it
better as well yeah
all right um next up is be unemotional
in business that's that's the incredible
hulk there
um
so
and i've mentioned this before
that a lot of the best investors i've
worked for a lot of billionaires and i
won't say which ones ever
but some of them it feels like they were
borderline aspergers um
and they were unemotional
and i think that's one of the reasons
why they're very successful
but you can train yourself to sort of be
like that you got to check your emotions
at the door
and never get too emotional in business
and remember warren buffett
said the new york stock exchange
is the only store in the world where
consumers sell stuff and it goes on sale
i want you to be unemotional
and i'm a very positive person however
when things go incredibly well for you i
don't want you to high-five and throw a
big party et cetera unless it's a
massive milestone whatever in business
i want you stay level-headed
and you got to stay level-headed because
if the opposite happens
you'll freak out
check your emotions at the door
be unemotional about business always
always always
uh and you can condition yourself to do
that too
like when i come home from work i
condition myself so that when i touch
the front door
and start to turn it
i leave all my stress and thoughts about
work at work
inside my house it's a sacred temple my
kids christine my kids and i my family
but i conditioned myself that way and
you can condition yourself as well to
check your emotions at the door
when you show up to work even so you're
not emotional especially when it comes
to finance
yeah
all right next up is the most important
investment characteristic which you can
probably guess here
has to do with horses
the jockey me and the dude on top of the
horse the jockey is more important than
the horse and what that means is
the management team or the founder or
founders they're more important than the
business model the horse is the business
model in this analogy
okay always remember that always always
always and
when you assess a management team
um make sure that they get you excited
about the vision they paint for you so
to speak or the dream they're selling to
you
because
the business model will change if it's
an early stage company
but i want you to be incredibly
passionate because the potential
investor
that's watching you present
they're thinking themselves
does this person get me excited deep
down in my belly
about this business opportunity
and i know
that that business opportunity that the
market will probably change one day but
i want to know that this this this
person that's trying to sell me the idea
will be able to sell me on another idea
or be able to adapt and get me excited
about another
business model or whatever it might be
or new product they might be offering a
new service
if i invest if i invest
and as mark cuban said
ideas are commodities by execution is
not
and mark cuban is is the dude that
he sold um broadcast.com
uh to youtube for or pardon me to yahoo
for several billion dollars in the late
90s and
that could have been youtube actually
but it wasn't they messed up the
acquisition
but mark cuban also said
you only have to be right in business
one time
so just remember that when you keep
trying to write different business plans
if you fail a couple times
so what
you will be successful eventually and i
don't have to read you that that quote
on the wall uh with michael jordan there
yeah you get it
okay next up we've got um yeah hire
slowly and and fire quickly so
when you hire somebody
the best way to do it is to
really over interview
um and so
like when i worked at goldman sachs like
the smartest people in the world didn't
work there i mean they hired me
but they they hired people that really
got along well
and we had to go through a gazillion
interviews a ton of them like 40
sometimes 40 or 50. it was nuts
but the jerk factor is very very low
and they took their time thank god
because
one stupid
or one employee with with a bad attitude
i should say can destroy
an entire company it's true you've all
been doing you've done group projects in
school or at work where there's one jerk
that just destroys everything it's not
worth it it's not worth it so when you
interview people i want you to make sure
that they are interviewed multiple times
in different settings
under different amounts of pressure and
i say with love my heart
so interview them maybe at a breakfast
meeting
uh do a two-on-one lunch meeting uh have
them present to five or six people in
your company if you have that many
people
um you know go out maybe for dinner with
them and their spouse
um and see them in all aspects of their
life
because they can't act the whole time
you know if if they're the salty earth
they're good people
um you'll know you'll know and usually i
know within 30 seconds
um whether or not i trust them and go
with your gut too
because you learn
by by you know by through business over
over many decades
that your gut is often right and we've
all gotten burned in our personal lives
and professional lives too
and we end up telling ourselves you know
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me go with your gut go with
your gut because a lot of times you're
when you get screwed over in business or
personally speaking when you're younger
remember when you broke your heart the
first time it hurt and it never hurt
that bad again right you kind of learn
you kind of learn um and and in
hindsight after you get screwed over in
business or personally you tell yourself
damn it i knew
i knew
go with your gut go with your gut but
take a long time to hire people and when
you're interviewing people
make sure
that
you feel it in your heart
that they're not interviewing for a job
they're interviewing for a passion
okay and they'll be way more productive
that way trust me on this
the difference between hiring an average
engineer and an incredible engineer
is 10 times more in performance
and a lot of engineers actually they
love what they do you know they just
they're they're they're nerds they they
love they grew up like like i did you
know playing video games
i was gonna include this i don't know i
guess i didn't but this was uh
i guess this is the the first um
joystick i had for my um this is the
apple
predecessor that with the apple 2e
actually but a lot of a lot of people
that are engineers and nice to be a
software engineer too
we grew up loving it like these are some
of the programs that i i you know i
developed for microsoft and other stuff
too but i loved it man it was fun
you know and that's why a lot of
technology companies do well
because the people are so passionate
about what they're doing
they just love it
so make sure that whoever you're
interviewing
is just as passionate as you are
they've got to love it they've got to
absolutely love it
otherwise if it feels like a job then
you'll you'll never put your dent in the
universe as a company
all right oh actually let me let me go
back here um
yeah so higher slowly and fire quickly
um let me talk a little bit more about
um about firing i i talked about it
briefly and i remember the first time i
had to fire somebody it was it was hell
and obviously it was way harder for the
person that i let go
and i didn't know what the hell to do
and i was nervous
and and it sounds stupid for me saying
this because it sucks that i'd let the
other person go but you have to do it
and so what i did was i called um one of
my good friends i went to mcgill with a
guy named mike ball
he was my fraternity too great guy
and and i asked him because his dad was
the head of hr uh human resources at att
or ncr for years
and i asked him how do i do it
and and he helped me out with some
advice and and i took what he told me
and a bunch of other
top silicon valley entrepreneurs i ask
their feedback i always over prepare for
everything
and here's the greatest it's what i
learned
when you let somebody go
you do it on a monday like i mentioned
before you sit down with them
and what you do is this
a bit repetitive here i'm sorry but i
have to do it
you start off by saying something
genuinely nice
and you do it like this
john
i just want to let you know that we
really appreciate
the great job you've done on the x
project making that up
and you know
everybody loves you here and you know
times are tough
but due to the the fact that and then
this is where you mentioned what they
did wrong
that you missed your i'm gonna make it
up you missed your quota
three quarters in a row
we have to let you go
then you pause and you say nothing
you pause
and dude it feels like freaking eternity
just waiting sometimes
you say nothing
and then they'll
they'll say something
um
a lot of times they'll know like they'll
kind of they figure it out it's
happening you know
like when they're they're called into
the meeting on a monday
they know they know or at least they
have a hunch and they probably know it's
coming because they haven't been
performing as well it's usually not a
massive surprise sometimes it is
and then you just wait
and they might say something rightly so
about you know what about my family and
that sort of thing and then you you have
a file there
and you say well we prepared for you uh
these these benefits uh and you wanna be
very generous of course
and if it's a bigger company you'll have
somebody from human resources
in the room as well
and if you don't know what to do and
it's a tiny company it's just you and
somebody else or a couple people you can
always get a lawyer to help you call
them and ask them how do i do this you
have to do it the right way
and
then what happens and most of the time
people are cool about it but i've been
in situations where
a colleague of mine was let go
and they had to call security
and you can always get a security guard
uh you can you can
hire one
or you can get somebody in a bigger
company uh to be standing by
just outside the room just in case just
in case
and if they're a bit abrasive uh or you
know the person that you let go
um
you can always say
and you could be firm you know if
they're being really pushy you could say
do i have to call security
like that like that so anyway and then
what happens usually is they
they look at the paperwork quickly and
and then they they shake your hand
that's it
yeah
yeah
and you got to be careful too because if
you let go and it's happened to
everybody happen to me
um if you're let go
if you're not careful
and if if you're abrasive or a jerk well
first of all you're gonna make it easier
for them to let you go
but if you're a jerk about it
good luck getting another job
because that's your reference whoever
lets you go is your former boss
that's your reference
so be good about it like when i was let
go
i didn't like
my boss he put his hand out
uh and
i didn't shake it i gave him a hug
and i hugged him so [ __ ] hard i broke
all his ribs no i'm just kidding i'm
just kidding
it was bogus um
i i made the firm money i have no idea
what happened but i was strategic um i
think he was threatened by me but it is
what it is
but i'm so glad it happened because in
hindsight many many many many years
later i look back i'm like thank you god
for guiding me down that path a
different path
sometimes you won't understand in life
why things happen and then years later
you look back and you'll say
you know what as painful as that was
professionally for me it was the best
thing that could have happened to me
because it forced me down this path here
so um but just yeah be careful on your
way out and and
if any of you have left a company
and
you didn't live on leave on great terms
and somebody asked for a reference
you don't have to get your old boss as a
reference you can always have a former
colleague
a buddy of yours who can even write a
nice recommendation on linkedin
so that's just food for thought yeah uh
and when you let people go you gotta
you gotta let them go fast
it's so hard
and after you let them go say you wait
six months too long
after you let them go you're like damn
it they hurt productivity i should let
them go way way before way way way way
earlier it's so hard though man it's
i've got a big heart
um but at the same time you got to put
business first
and if it if it ever
if your heart gets in the way of
business sometimes just think to
yourself this is all things to say but i
have to
you're hurting your family if you don't
do it sooner
and you're hurting them as well because
they're rotting away at work
when they could be doing something else
they're more passionate about
and i know it doesn't make sense to a
lot of us right now
but many years later you'll look back
and
you might be glad
that you were let go yeah
all right
okay next up um we've got touch hand
only once
um i didn't know what icon to use here
what graphics so
i found like an old file cabinet thing
because
i got this one from my dad
and this is old school device it's great
though
he said
if you ever
if you ever write a letter
and
you're a little bit negative in the
letter
or mean by accident or whatever it is
and if you're emotional
don't mail that letter yet
take that letter my dad he's he's arabic
from egypt he'd say take the letter put
it in the drawer
and then i can't do his accent well i'm
sorry but
open it the next day the drawer next
morning after you sleep on it and if you
still feel the same way after you read
it then send it
and that's great advice it's great
advice because
in this digital reality now
um
you could send an email when you're in a
crap mood
and
destroy your life
or hurt your career a lot
and what i used to do is i used to have
christine who's my wife and my shrink
and my wife and my shrink
um she um i used to ever read some of my
emails i'm like did i sound
how's the tone here that sort of thing
because things can be really
misinterpreted you know like if somebody
types in all caps which i never do but
it's like they're yelling and usually
with almost all my emails since day one
i use the word please and thank you and
all it's just on my birth thanks
something i've always done yeah
touch hand only once
yeah yeah oh my god i think i screwed
that up but screw it let me go back
there
i meant to say something else there but
that was good advice screw it we'll keep
that in there it's fine
touch hand only once i'm such an idiot
it's an old school business thing which
is this in the old days you used to get
inter-office memos and there's a string
on it you unwrap open the envelope
and the best business people in the
world will say
when a memo comes in your hand or an
email or whatever it is
only let it touch your hand one time
and take care of everything right away
if you can unless it's something that's
gonna take forever to do and i've
adopted that actually in many aspects of
my life
and this is gonna sound out there but it
saves me time
when i make a salad at night and i love
salad with oil and vinegar and salt and
pepper and i have this awesome uh bagel
spice it's it's it's it's what you put
on everything bagels but it's a spice i
get it from trader joe's the best ever
but i only let all those things touch my
hand once so i open the cupboard up once
and i take all those out at the same
time once
you put them all back in at once right i
know it sounds silly
but if you use that mentality you will
save a ton of time a ton of time
so
touch hand only once
okay
all right so now i want you to please go
to your workbook
and click on number 10 meaning section
10
on the front page
and then i want you to take three
minutes please
and write down notes on how you can
apply the lessons in section 10 to
enhance your career or make you happier
you've got three minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
all right let's move on now to section
number 11
which is called navigating corporate
politics and swimming with sharks yeah
all right
so
the first one here is keep that letter
in your drawer i i i'm such an idiot i
jumped the gun i already talked about
this one so i'm just gonna skip it okay
but just keep in mind that
a lot of times in business
you don't get to the next level because
of politics which sucks and i'm going to
give you some i guess some some tips
here
on how to um
how to swim with the shark so to speak
as much as i hate that
so
religion and politics
leave them at home
don't ever talk about them in work ever
ever ever
because the way that politics works
usually in most countries there's two
parties
party one or party two you know or
sometimes there's three like in canada
there's there's a bunch actually there's
progressive conservative which is like
right wing relatively speaking
you got liberals and then you've got um
ndp
which i can't stand i mean ndp yeah
which is uh
they're more socialist yeah yeah
sorry about that sort of
and in america you've got republicans
and democrats and republicans means that
you're more right-wing and democrats
means that you're less right-wing you're
more left-wing
and i live here in california on the
left coast
get myself in trouble there i gotta be
careful
but
if you tell people what your political
affiliation is and i think i'm probably
a libertarian i believe in the power of
the individual and that you can
accomplish anything so i'm less so
married to these parties although i will
swap every now and then okay
but if you tell somebody that you're in
one part you like one type of politician
then half the people will hate you or
not like you as much i don't know what
half
but just be careful it's not worth it so
what do you do when politics come up at
work
well you just
don't talk
if a bunch of people are around
or if somebody tries to bait you into it
you can say two words
i understand
and that won't let them know that you're
one with one party or the other party i
i understand that will help
uh and religion is is is tough it's
tough um
it's really really hard because i am
really passionate about stuff but
and i'm
i'm very respectful of every religion on
the planet
but just be careful at class or at uh at
um at work getting nervous now yeah yeah
just be careful yeah
all right next up is um unjustified
criticism is a disguised compliment i
had to mention this one twice okay and
so yeah if somebody
criticizes you unfairly you got to tell
yourself
thanks man
like don't say it out loud it'll drive
them nuts
um
don't say it out loud it'll it won't
help you
but just tell that to yourself and your
mind and that will say it is
yeah
yeah so remember that
unjustify and write it down please write
it down
unjustified criticism is a disguised
compliment
that will add years to your life it'll
take away a lot of stress in your heart
and your mind as well
yeah
all right um what do we have next number
number 54.
come on slides move faster there we go
good all right next one is um how to
talk buying people's backs
and that's um
looks like a nail file but i it's it's
actually a butter knife um
i didn't want to have a real real knife
whatever but the best way is not to do
it at all i know it sounds silly and
you're like chris seriously like i'm an
adult here right i know
but don't get tied into that like office
gossip like stay away from gossip at the
office
um
like sometimes it's you're around the
water cooler and somebody will be
gossiping you're like yeah yeah you're
interested in hearing it
but just don't don't be a part of that
people won't trust you and if you gossip
even a little bit about somebody at work
they'll appreciate hearing it
but they won't trust you
you know it's like somebody that
backstabs their wife or their husband
you know says something bad about them
um you're like dude i can never trust
you
so stay away from gossip at work it's
not worth it it's not worth it at all
yeah
all right next up is
observe and then make your move
so every company has a slightly
different corporate culture and every
team does
and every board does as well
so when you join a new company
i don't want you to make your move right
away and try to really impress people
right away
hear me out
i want you to question things at first
like question in your mind
and really observe how the system works
because every company's a little bit
different
you know
and be nice to the assistants please
anybody that isn't is an [ __ ]
plus the assistants have been there
longer than most people and they
probably worked with their boss at the
previous company as well and they know
how to get stuff done
and if you confide in them
and get them to mentor you they'll love
it
they'll trust you you'll trust them and
they'll help you with your career
yeah yeah you can really
you can really understand what kind of a
person somebody is or how much jerk they
are by how they treat assistance
so observe
observe how the system works at first
before making your move you got one shot
to really impress people just sit back a
bit don't be lazy
but don't talk up too much initially
just observe how it works you know
quietly
observe the system because every com
every company is is a little bit
different a little bit different yeah
all right next up is the army promotes
you because of this um so
it's so hard sometimes to to deal with
authority and
not talk back and just do what you're
told to do and
but sometimes if you
if you kind of follow blindly i hate to
say
sometimes it helps you with your career
a lot uh and you might be frustrated but
it in the long run it'll it'll pay off
because you'll get what you want and if
you're frustrated enough you can leave
anyway but the biggest thing here is
that
when i used to work in consultant
it was kind of like the army
you know it's when there's a war the
troops go and fight where the war is
if you're a consultant
you're sent wherever the client is
wherever all the any any it might be a
different country and i've been all over
the place doing that many countries
and
there's actually um
there's a guy who who used to be the
co-chairman of goldman sachs
and he actually came and lectured at
columbia university
uh and i think his name was uh was was
stephen levitt i think yeah
um actually i gotta go find out right
now because his son actually is the guy
that wrote game of thrones
let me let me go here here sorry i i
have to find out right now
uh but but i remember he was there and i
was in new york and i was about to join
goldman and goldman wanted me to start
my career in tokyo
and and i didn't want to go
and so what i did um
hold on a second bend the office guy's
last name i'll talk about this guys
what i did was it was i said to him i'll
get that second
i said do i really have to go
and he stared me down in front of
everybody there's like 60 people in the
class said
yes you do
so if you want to get promoted to a
senior senior level in companies
sometimes you have to move if they tell
you to move it sucks
uh but but if you do that you take one
for the team
but don't go
unless you get something promised in
return
you know basically say i'll go but i
want to make sure i get promoted
and you can hold up you can kind of use
that card and they'll promote you as
they send you
um but this guy's name um
the guy that wrote like game of thrones
uh he um okay so he was the the
screenwriter david benioff
and his dad was a professor steven
somebody i gotta know because he changed
his last name benioff yeah steven
friedman it was steven friedman yeah
yeah he changed his last name from
benioff to friedman because there's lots
of david friedman that are writers but
that's his dad yeah his dad was um
goldman sachs where is he getting here
now now i'm curious stephen friedman
that's right here is the guy this is the
guy that that stared me down yeah yeah
then eventually he went into government
because
at goldman sachs i worked at goldman for
years and i understand after i left why
so many successful politicians from
goldman sachs er come out of uh by so
many successful politicians come out of
goldman sachs yeah yeah it's tough place
to work but it's fun too i'm proud it's
on my resume and again they don't have
the smartest people in the world
way off track okay anyway
next up
mr bean
uh facetime is important i hate it
you know but but early on your career
when you're first starting out
you got to be first in
and you got to be last out
okay it's something i i call philo first
and last out
it sucks and hopefully you don't have
kids and
all that stuff um when you first start
your career
but but it's important it's important um
i hate it i hate it but it's important
face time is important and michael
bloomberg who started he's a billionaire
he started bloomberg and he was mayor of
new york whatever for a while that's
what he did early in his career
he would show up for anybody
and um
yeah that that's base time was important
i got that one from him actually yeah
he's done quite well
all right next up is dta which stands
for don't trust anyone
sharks are tough to spot sometimes it's
so true it's so true
um
usu when you go with your gut usually
you can tell somebody's a shark but
sometimes you don't know like if push
comes to shove
and you're competing with somebody get
promoted at work
um
don't trust them man
don't trust anyone like just be really
really careful
like don't date anybody at work either
ever unless you're sure it's uh if
you're positive this is the one this is
the one yeah just be careful dta don't
trust anyone okay
and i debated whether i include this one
or not and actually in my book i renamed
this chapter it was it was chapter 59 in
the paperback version and the kindle
version
um and i actually changed the title
because i angered people then i'm
including it now so it's good i don't
care
so um
a valuable lesson about donald trump
so
and when i wrote this book is before
trump got elected but but years ago i i
read i read
a book from trump called uh the art of
the deal and this guy can get a deal
done
he can't nice let's be intellectually
honest he can't especially in business
but he said something um
years ago that made a lot of sense and
when i first heard it i thought oh my
god that's
i don't know if i agree but he said
you have to remind people
of your accomplishments
otherwise you'll never reach
you know your
highest your potential in life
and as a canadian you know growing up
we're very humble whatever it just
wasn't our nature
you know um
you know wayne gretzky used to say
when when
when you when you lose say nothing
when you win say even less
but but trump is right trump is right um
if you don't remind people of of your
accomplishments you'll never get
promoted
uh you'll never get you'll never be able
to raise money
you'll never get customers you got to
remind people and and sometimes it's as
simple as you're trying to get a big
contract
in your sales person
you have to remind the person that
you're meeting with after you bond
which other big contracts you've signed
in the past big reference customers if
you're allowed to disclose it
and you have to brag about your
accomplishments as well
um and there's ways to do it like
i'm going to brag in a second
and and you'll see how i'm going to brag
and it won't come across as as being a
big brag here we go oh my god i talk a
lot
i'm humbled to say
that i think
that i'm a very good judging character
so you i i through the beginning part
and i'm humbled to say that you know
whatever uh but yeah and trump certainly
doesn't do it that way
uh but if you don't um
if you don't remind people your
accomplishments you'll never get a
promotion
you won't
you'll never get a raise you'll let you
never get a job you'll never get
anything in life
you have to do it you have to it's going
to be humble but at times you have to
brag it's a do or die mentality
okay
uh and and yeah here um ask often how am
i doing how am i doing and i got this
one from another goldman sachs partner
that i met with
when i was at coleman you have to ask
how am i doing often not all the time
but every month or two
meet with your manager and ask her him
you know okay you know i really enjoy
being here at the hermitage or whatever
you know what i mean
i'd love you can please provide me some
feedback on on how i can contribute more
to the team
even more at the time
and they'll start off by saying positive
things if they're a good manager and
then they'll tell you additional things
that you can do
and you can even ask them was it you
know to get promoted to the next level
like what else do i need to do what else
do i need to do
and they'll tell you and once you
accomplish that stuff remind them
when they're in a good mood it's kind of
like asking mom and dad for something
only when they're in a good mood remind
them that when you've accomplished those
things so you can get that promotion
but you have to ask how i'm doing often
and if you do that you'll most likely
never get fired or at least surprised uh
and fired yeah always ask for feedback
otherwise
you just don't know how good of a job
you're doing
all right um and the only way to get
promoted or a raise
and i was looking for the energizer
bunny i couldn't find it so i threw the
durabell
duracell battery in which takes a
licking and keeps on ticking that's what
they used to say i think so or is that
time asked can't remember
uh but the bottom line is you just got
to be relentless you got to be
relentless and
ask over and over and over and over and
over and over again to get a raise or
promotion and there's tactful ways to do
it too and you don't have to be annoying
about it
um or piss off your manager
you meet with them every couple months
and when you ask how am i doing
that's when you ask
you know it and maybe you strike when
they aaron's hot when you achieved a
milestone and they give you great
feedback
then you you say awesome awesome
do you have time for coffee now
and you go for coffee uh and you'll say
thank you very much for the kaufman i
appreciate it it's it's been great being
a member of this team and together we've
accomplished a lot
you know what i'm doing here right
so that then you say well i'd love to
ask you if it's okay
what do i need to do and it's really
making this it's really expensive living
um here with the family and whatnot as
you know and i have to provide and so
i'm
i'd love to ask you please
what do i need to accomplish how much
more how much about more value can i add
and what kind of value can i add to the
team
in order to get a raise or a promotion
and and they'll give you the criteria
and the second you achieve those
criteria
and your boss is in a good mood and it's
not too busy crazy at work
it's a slow day meet with them and ask
otherwise you won't get it you won't get
it
people that make ceo are ones that have
asked that have asked many times to be
promoted and many times for a race
they're sales people they're selling
themselves they're relentless
and they brag as well about their
accomplishments tactfully tactfully
if you don't remind people of your
accomplishments
and if you don't ask for a raise or
promotion
you'll never get it you'll never get it
it's kind of like when you were younger
and you were in school
you kept your head down
and when
when you did well in a test
you were congratulated your parents are
happy teachers are happy everyone's
happy you were happy
then you graduate and you start working
and you keep your head down and you work
hard and you do well
and you think to yourself well
somebody's going to notice me just like
in school
and then you look around you're like
dude why are these people getting
promoted instead of me i accomplished so
much more than they did
oh my gosh that guy got a big raise i
didn't what's up with that
it's because they asked
so you gotta ask
all right um next up is uh there is a
plan b uh before you quit
uh and that's by the way it's an
american power conversion uh older
backup battery i've got four of them
here uh running just in case because i
blew a fuse once or twice because of all
this equipment and lights and stuff in
the air conditioning too
but i put it there because
before you quit
let's say you got a job a job offer from
another company for more money and a
better position whatever
whoa that scared me
sorry that was my alarm that remind me
to put the kids to bed but there's no
school tomorrow so it's fine we're good
we're good
um
sorry about that
so before you quit
think to yourself why are you quitting
you're probably quitting because this
other
company is paying you more money or this
other company is giving you
responsibilities that you enjoy more or
this other company
is giving you a different type of role
in a different geographical location
whatever it is
you got nothing to lose
so when when you go to tell your manager
that you're resigning
um just let them know that you've you've
been offered a job
and
before quitting
there's nothing wrong with asking them
if they could
match that offer
or find you that other role internally
so you can transfer
you got nothing to lose nothing to lose
and everything to gain
okay
uh next up is avoid this at all costs
okay and duff beer what is duff beer
from
you got to tell you what duff beer is
from um
it's a great cartoon that i've been
watching since the 80s and i can't
believe it's still on
uh and i'll tell you what it is in a
minute if you don't already know
and conan o'brien used to be one of the
writers
okay but i want you to avoid alcohol at
all costs um at all events right and i i
used to drink i don't drink anymore and
not judging anybody it's fun
but i want you to be careful and what my
what my my grandfather god bless him he
gave me advice as well
um when i was going to my first job i
asked him i asked a ton of people for
advice and he said to me he said chi chi
christie
when you go to a corporate party
if if you're forced to drink just take
that drink whatever just i don't know
when no one's looking throwing the
plants
yeah and i thought i'm not going to do
that he said or what you can also do
is just get a 7-up with lime in it or
sprite with lime in it because that
looks like a gin and tonic or something
anyway
just be careful with alcohol at work
it's it's so weird because i used to go
out and party whatever and i worked at
hedge fund industry in different
companies i had a blast like i have no
regrets
but a lot of people they let their guard
down right and a lot of these rules i've
taught you today are humble lessons
whatever like don't trust anyone
whatever
all that stuff like
dude people people let their cards down
when they drink at corporate events
um and
you know let them fall in their knives
so to speak for their swords that was
nothing to say but you know what i'm
getting at i'd rather
i'd rather you rise to the top
um yeah
so anyway
that took me a while to create there
there you go now you know where it's
from now you know where it's from that
that's that's uh mr burns
uh front from the simpsons uh and he had
this guy named smithers that worked for
him and i remember one episode he said
mr burns i love you
in that shirt
that's funny
so number 64. and i couldn't get the
eyes to work i don't know why so i just
threw silver everywhere and had to
recolor it but
um
number 64 is
don't ever go over your boss's head
um
unless you have to and i'll explain what
that means so
don't ever talk to your boss's boss
like you can say hello good morning
whatever it is
but just be careful just be careful uh
and i've done it before just
naively trying to help and i've added a
ton of value
and then my boss got jealous and
yeah it happens
just be careful
however
if you think you're going to be let go
or if you work for a jerk
and you got nothing to lose
take that risk go to your boss's boss
when your boss is not around add a
tremendous amount of
value i worked at a very big hedge fund
once not gonna say which one
and i got an offer from an even bigger
hedge fund
and
the owner of the hedge fund that i was
leaving said
if you
stay we might give you a more senior
role and he was implying i guess i might
get my boss's job
i i didn't have the heart i can't do it
i couldn't do it
even though i've been for a heck of a
lot more money i just can't it's not me
it's not me but that option's there
yeah yeah so don't go over your boss's
head yeah now you know what duff beer is
from yeah
now i got that song duff beer for me in
my head
okay here we go
all right moving on speaking of the
simpsons
um my uncle i have to cross arms like
like like homer
that's homer simpson so funny his name
is homer like that's supposed to be like
an intellectual name
my uncle who worked at general uh
electric um
i remember asking him when i was like
what was i was 22 when i went to
accenture in 94. yeah
i remember asking for advice
and and he said to me he said something
i never understood
he said
well he said also don't ever date
anybody at work um he was right about
that unless it's a sure thing because he
said you'll get fired or they'll get
fired or both whatever
it's yeah
but he said to me something i didn't
understand he said chris just be a nice
dumb guy
i was like what the hell does that mean
i understand that
it's my uncle mike he's great i love him
he said just be a nice dumb guy and i
didn't get it but i kind of get it now
years later
years later
and um i think he was probably my age
when he told me that's interesting wow
basically what he was telling me was
don't don't come across as a threat to
anybody like
especially your own level
it don't be dumb whatever like that like
he's mentioning here but just don't come
across the threat just be you know be a
nice guy or a nice guy whatever and you
know don't try to show people up you
know impress people
you know your time to shine is when you
impress your clients or your boss or
your boss's boss if your boss is away
and you just happen to be yeah yeah
whatever
um just be nice dumb guy don't come
across the threat and a lot of times
people that make it to the top
sometimes they're sharks yes
but they rose to the ranks as well with
that mindset
you know it's
it's kind of like when you're
interviewing to get into a company
the hardest interviews are with people
that are the same rank as you because
they'll feel threatened yeah
so now i understand be a nice dumb guy
i'm homer yeah
all right uh next one is uh never never
complain isn't that a cool graphic i
found there uh explain is that a
complaint
yeah and dale carnegie said don't ever
criticize condemn or complain like let
other people whine about things at work
because if you complain just one time
the wrong person that feels threatened
by you somebody the same levels you
whatever
they'll say well chris was saying this
just just be careful just keep it in
your head keep it in your head and never
bring it home as well like don't like
when you go home don't don't complain to
your spouse they bottle it up
otherwise they'll they'll say how was
work together and you're like oh god
he's such a jerk again today it's not
worth and then your kids find out your
kids will say it and it slips whatever
just don't do it don't don't bring your
anger
and frustration home like that just
leave it at work just don't don't
complain and you know what dude
if you're frustrated good
it'll motivate you to get a better job
anyway you can move you're not a tree
yeah
focus always on what you can control in
life
all right
now please go to your workbook and click
on number 11 meaning section 11 on the
front page
and then i want you to please
spend three minutes writing down notes
on how you can apply
the lessons in section 11 to enhance
your career you've got three minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
section 12
only take advice from successful people
it's crucial
that you take advice from the right
people the right people always always
don't don't assume because somebody's
confident
they know what the hell they're talking
about
you know just take advice from people
that have done what you want to do
okay
so less number 67 is you need yodas
and i love this analogy
uh yoda was a mentor for those that
aren't star wars fans was a mentor
to um luke skywalker
and you need many yodas
you need lots of mentors in your life
and i want you to find people that
work in the industry that you want to
work in or currently working
or people that
have
a perfect lifestyle that you want
meaning they have a wonderful family
life
and
they found work-life balance and they're
successful and people love it when you
ask them to mention them as well
you gotta ask though right so you need
to have
many yodas and
if you're working at a company now and
you're not happy
in the division you're in you've got to
network internally and find mentors in
different divisions and get them to pull
you into their
their team or if push comes to shove and
there's a restructuring round and people
are going to be let go including you
maybe
you can call your yoda in another
department and ask them uh for help and
hopefully they can pull you in you need
yodas
all right next up is i want you to
follow people
that
inspire the heck out of you
or are doing what you want to do one day
or they're they're they're business
tycoons they're amazingly successful
and i put the graph there for audible
which is owned by amazon
and you can subscribe for a monthly fee
uh i recommend doing it it's a great
investment in yourself it's investment
education and i want you to listen to um
at least one or two books per month
from successful people
autobiographies
or biographies if you can't find them
and if you can find them where the the
person that that wrote it if it's an
autobiography narrates it themselves
like so richard branson that's even
better
because
you can hear their positivity in their
voice and people really let their cards
down once they've achieved success and
they want to share success and help you
to kind of pay that debt of gratitude
forward so to speak
so seek people
find people that have written books or
find the book names or whatever or or
the business tycoons or icons
and listen to their books
so that you can understand their
blueprint and why reinvent the wheel
they're going to help you do it anyway
they've done it
they've done it
and i'd love you all to one day
turn your business icon
uh into your rival turn your business
idle into your rival yeah
all right next up is
i've never never met a successful person
with
a negative attitude
and that there is uh one of searcher
branson's companies uh virgin atlantic
uh is
i've never met anybody that's really
really really successful in business
that doesn't have a positive attitude
because there's so much working against
you there's so many naysayers around you
saying you can't do it you can't do you
can't do it don't take a risk you might
fail people will laugh at you
effort
the people that make it big are the ones
that are really positive really positive
people make it big
so if you're not a positive person it
might be because you're hanging out with
people that bring you down
cut them off
you can control your environment
all right tied fun with that graphic
there all right next up is follow the
smart money i still want you to do your
own research on all investment ideas but
i also want you to be aware of
who smart investors are
and what type of investments they own
and just learn from them as well always
do your own research as well but i want
you to be aware
of
who the smart investors are
and follow the smart money so to speak
and
once you find investments that they've
invested in
then do a lot of research as well don't
just take their word for it
follow the smart money
okay actions speak louder than words
always too people like to vote with
their wallet
so please go to your workbook and click
on number 12
meaning section 12 on the front page
and as always please spend three minutes
writing down notes on how you can apply
the lessons in section 12 to enhance
your career thanks
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
next up let's talk about section number
13 which is called only the paranoid
survive
uh it's crucial to be paranoid about the
issues i'm going to talk about in a
second
and as you can tell there the one there
uh in the 13
those are those are chips and i've
actually got it right here let me go off
script
it's a
it's a pentium processor
so
i have those chips there in the 13 and
it's from intel because there's a
brilliant man
uh
who passed away recently god bless him
he's one of the co-founders of intel um
in his name is andy grove and he wrote a
great book that you guys should read
called only the paranoid survive
and he was so paranoid running intel
and
intel is is a company that makes chips
we all know that
but what many of us forget or didn't
know
as documented in his book which came out
in 95 95 or 96 i think i loved it
intel back in the 80s and the 70s
uh they made uh ram
right which is random access memory uh
which basically is
a commoditized industry there are little
chips that allow your computers to have
more programs open at once
and what happened was that the japanese
were so competitive with intel in the
early 80s
in japanese companies at that time
they were more interested in market
share
than they were in profit margin
and so they they basically flooded the
market with cheap ram
and
it intel could have gone out of business
and so what happened was uh andy grove
he he pivoted and he made the company
focus on a new product for them
called the intel processor they had
what's called the 286 and 386 and 486
and pentium and all that stuff whatever
you probably heard that in the past uh
but andy grove was was very very
paranoid
uh of the competition and bill gates was
the same way too when he was running
microsoft
bill gates used to say that microsoft is
always one and a half years away from
bankruptcy he even said that in the 90s
and of course we we know that there's no
way it would go bankrupt within a year
and a half
but that's how paranoid he was
you got to be paranoid like that like
i remember
i remember steven friedman and and i
have the the notebook actually and i
mentioned him before
his son is david benioff
friedman was a senior dude at at goldman
and i wrote down every word he said when
he came to guest lecture and i still had
the notebook and i read it the other day
but what he also said was
watch your back
because there's always somebody
that's smarter faster younger cheaper
than you that wants your job
uh and it's it's it's kind of
that's part of paranoia as well
so just be careful like like for me for
example
i've got multiple audio tracks right now
just in case it it messes up like i've
got i've got a blue yeti there i've got
this sure mic here i've got
cheap microphones and all the cameras as
well really really cheap ones just in
case and so we can synchronize the video
as well
um
just in case one of the things goes down
um and
whenever i give presentations i always
have a second laptop which i used to
borrow from a friend now i have my own
whatever i'm a nerd i know uh and when i
raised to give wedding speeches
i would use a laptop and i'd also bring
overhead slides just in case
always have a backup plan always always
always when i used to go to interviews i
would over prepare and i would always
bring a nutribar and put it in my pocket
because a lot of times they forgot to
feed you and if you can't if you if
you're hungry you can't think and so i
would go to the washroom and you know
gobble down the the nutribar
um but but but i was i was very paranoid
and i think it helped me a lot to have a
plan b and it made me more confident as
well in case something
didn't go well
i had a backup plan
so for intel
the backup plan was the processor
so you always want to have a plan b
always always always yeah only the
paranoid survive great book by andy
grove read it please
all right um next up is
hit this key
and lose your job
we are one little keystroke away from
destroying our lives
just be careful otherwise what can
happen your career is you can quickly be
end it
just be careful
triple check all your emails you are a
product a representation of of the
digital communication you send out
um
don't just spell check and grammar check
but also
think to yourself
can this be misinterpreted by anybody
and if you're ever emotional or upset
just
get away from email man
or from your your cell phone or whatever
it is just be careful your career can be
ended quickly and this is a mechanical
keyboard here and i love these clicky
keyboards by the way i have one like
that it's by a german company called
dust keyboard yeah
all right next up is let the secret out
and you're done
and that secret is
that you want to leave your company and
go back to school
even if it's for whatever degree
don't ever tell anybody
don't ever tell anybody
that you want to leave
unless you want to get a reference
letter whatever which you can ask in a
more diplomatic way which i can talk
about if you want me to
but
if you tell somebody that you're
interested in leaving to go back to
school at some point
you know they might
they might say oh that's great that's
awesome i agree it's a good idea
but then
the next time a recession hits
and business is very cyclical
and
companies tend to over hire when things
are going well and they tend to over
fire meaning they cut into muscle not
just fat when things are not going well
but if they have to the way it works in
big companies is
if companies have to you know cut
expenses so they can make their
quarterly earnings when they report
earnings
what will happen is
management will tell
all the bosses in all the different
divisions i need one head each that's
how it works it's quantitative
and
your boss will think themselves well
and i'm going to make this up
chris is great he's one of my best
performers
but he told me a while i remember a
while ago he told me he wants to go back
to school
so if he's going to leave anyway i might
as well choose him
dta don't trust anyone don't tell
anybody at all at work that you're ever
thinking of of going back to school okay
all right next up is oh dude this one
was so dope that was boba fett boba fett
was the best character ever uh and he
was barely in star wars he was in
revenge of the the jedi for like a
nanosecond
and then han solo turned around and he
fell down into that big hole he died
when hans was
hans couldn't see and by the way i've
got to go there i'm so sorry i don't
care i'm going to do this i'm i'm a star
wars fan
so
do i have my star wars thing there it's
right here yeah yeah
all right
so
there's politics in movies as well if
you're a real jerk of an actor or
actress
you won't get rehired and that's what
happened apparently hearsay whatever
with megan fox remember she's in the
transformers and stuff you don't see her
anymore because she was
she was difficult to anyway on one of
those productions you can google it if
you want to
and a lot of great actors that you don't
hear about anymore it's because they
were difficult there's politics you know
at their job as well like there's
politics with us that's why i'm talking
about sharks but i have to talk about
harrison for it because he's he's he's
awesome
he was so difficult to deal with
in empire strikes back
so difficult when they were making it
that what they did was
they didn't know if they were going to
bring him back in to return the jedi
and so what they did at the end of the
empire strikes back is they froze him
remember that he was frozen um anyway
and they ended up bringing him back and
and
that's why we're talking about boba fett
when he couldn't see because he was
unfrozen for a while and return the jedi
he yeah anyway
but you gotta admit
boba fett's pretty pretty dope pretty
badass yeah
yeah
so
i always have a personal backup plan
okay
and
what remind me to do this is because
boba fett's dad or something had a
gazillion versions of
himself made cloned whatever
but always have a backup plan in terms
of
what do you do
if your company
might let you go
um
and a lot of times you won't know
because what can happen in business is
everything is going well and then we go
into this horrific recession in a
nanosecond
or something like um
like a black swan event occurs
like like a virus or whatever it is or
terrorist events or
i don't know
the 2008 crash whatever it's something
you can't control they call it black
swan because black swans are rare
they're usually not black yeah
so
the backup plan is this
i don't want you to be loyal
to any company that's right
you're thinking chris that's not ethical
[ __ ] loyalty
i'm sorry i swore but i want you to
remember this
no company is going to be loyal to you
and your family
okay when when when push comes to shove
they have to let people go you got to be
loyal to your family first
than yourself than the company that's
right
that's right you got to look out for
yourself and if you don't look out for
yourself and have a plan b
then you're hurting your family
or your future family
and so if a headhunter calls you that's
why that's why i put both that's right
he's uh he's a headhunter or something
or a bounty hunter bounty hunter that's
why i put him
but if if a headhunter calls you
um saying that they're interested in
interviewing you to maybe hire you or
whatever
take that meeting take every damn
meeting
and just don't meet with them in a place
too close to your work obviously and and
by the way if if your company gives you
um
if they give you a cell phone at work
if you have um
if you have enough money
to do it i want you to get the exact
same one
for yourself
because at work you know you're gonna be
using that phone whatever
but i also want you to have another
phone just in case
in case you want to make personal calls
or in case and it's a good investment
in case uh some other company calls you
and you're setting up an interview you
don't want
you don't want anybody to be able to
fish through your emails and personal
stuff also
if you work for a jerk and you will one
day
uh i'm not hiring though in case you're
thinking i'm a jerk no but if you work
for a jerk um
and this jerk makes you stay late at
work
just for facetime whatever and it's
bogus
i want you
on your laptop whatever
to use your personal wi-fi network with
these things
and write a business plan
on their nickel that's right if legally
you're allowed to start screw that i
don't care i'm i'm a pit bull and a pork
chop helping you
always have that plan b
always always always please yeah
all right next up is question motives
and why do i have an old tv there
i i have a tv because um
whenever somebody's being interviewed on
television
i i want you to
before accepting what they say is gospel
or being true or legitimate or whatever
i want you to ask yourself
what's their angle
why are they saying that
what's their bias remember bias always
if it's a ceo
they're saying great things about the
company because
they're sales people that's their
company they're not being unethical
but they're biased
of course they're going to say great
things always
and if somebody's interviewed that's a
money manager like maybe they're a
portfolio manager at a mutual fund or
something
of course you're going to talk about the
stocks they own even if they disclose it
of course they're going to say positive
things about it there's a bias they want
to get you to bottom to push them higher
so always ask yourself
why are they doing that
you know why you gotta in your in your
mind question motives and it's part of
game theory which is like chess thinking
a couple heads uh moves ahead of what
somebody might do
it's game theory
always question somebody's motives not
out loud but just in your mind you know
it's not as politics and work and
paranoia within within corporate
environments is is all about
game theory and chess moves you want to
understand somebody like what their
background is you know what their
interests are and just more about them
you know that's game theory you're doing
your research
um
you want to think like they're going to
think when you meet with them
and you can always go to their twitter
profile to see who they follow to learn
more about them yeah
or the bottom of their linkedin profile
to see which companies or people they
follow and by the way don't ever follow
politicians ever ever ever on linkedin
or on twitter you know if you're curious
what donald trump's going to say on
twitter you can go and type up the real
donald trump and see for a while but
don't follow you know even if you're
republican it doesn't matter
just
yeah be careful
all right um
that's paranoia i guess
all right and that's what the back of
tvs used to look like there yeah they
weren't dude they were massive back then
massive yeah
all right uh so now i want you to go to
your workbook and click number 13
meaning section 13
on the front page
and then spend three minutes writing
down notes
on how you can apply the lessons we just
talked about here
in section 13
to enhance your your career you got
three minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right section 14 risk taking i love
this one i love this one
it's crucial you take the right kinds of
risks you'll never get ahead in life
unless you take risks and plenty of
risks and embrace failure embrace
failure and fail fast and i'll get to
that soon
all right so let's talk about risks
yeah fail fast and fail
early
okay um
if if you start a company
give yourself two years
and after two years
i want you to ask yourself
if i had known
about all the issues that i uncovered i
discovered over the past two years would
i have still have started this company
and the answer is no
pull the plug
move on
you're going to start a lot of companies
in life and as mark cuban said you only
have to be right in business one time
every single amazing business person you
know of
you only know about their successes you
don't know about the crappy companies
they started and they failed the best
you know like uh
bill gates and paula allen together
they started a company called trafford
ida where they had these little wires on
roads you know when you go over it
and it counts cars they failed
yeah so fail fast and fail early and
don't give a damn what anybody thinks
anyway because you are going to make it
huge one day regardless what anybody
thinks you give a damn what people think
anyway fail fast fail early keep moving
forward
all right next up is
opm not the drug
but opm stands for other people's money
and that's danny devito
great actor funny man
um he was in this movie called other
people's money which is a great movie
you gotta watch it because it will
explain to you
what is private equity in a fun way it's
a great movie and like every hollywood
movie the rich person loses at the end
or is a schmuck or becomes nice or
whatever it is what it is there's no
exception every movie because i have to
appeal to everybody whatever
i should stop now
but um i actually learned that from rush
limbaugh is that terrible years ago
uh the the rich person's always a
schmuck a movie but but watch that movie
if you can because it'll really explain
you what what opm other people's money
and how private equity works but the
reason i put opm here
in devito
is because
i don't want you to use your own money
to start companies
if you have a lot of money yes you can
but i don't want you to put your family
at risk or put too much stress on
yourself
i want you to raise money from high net
worth investors
but i want you to raise money from high
net worth investors initially
okay
now the sales cycle is quite shorter
than going after venture capital and if
you network and find something in common
with people and you present with passion
right from your heart like i'm going to
teach you you will be able to raise
money
and when you raise money i want you to
make sure that you pay yourself the same
salary at least that way you make at
that previous company
you're at
because i don't want you to bring your
stress home
i want you to
make sure your family is happy and
you're happy as well
use other people's money you can do it
if if you don't think you can
then you won't be able to
but you know it as henry ford said
whether or not you think you can do it
you're right
be relentless like a pit bull on a pork
chop
and it will happen i promise you
all right next up is
um don't invest if all the founders have
left and i put here and you can go if
you want just do it do a search um
on on me chris
haroon venture beats so venture beat is
the
it's it's like the wall street journal
but for
uh for uh for venture capital
um and then you just you'll find this
article i wrote years ago uh and i wrote
about this and i really do believe it
that um
when i found and i was just a guest
columnist i love writing like it's fun
for me and it's good for your career too
and we'll talk about embracing the media
really really soon how can help you it's
free pr
everybody wins they win you win
so network a lot to get meetings with
the media and i'll talk more about that
later on but when um
when a founder leaves a company
when all the founders leave a company
and are no longer engaged at all
you gotta run for the exits man
you do
because most of the time
that company won't be as successful in
the long run
because what happens is founders run a
company
and the board loves the founder
and investors love the founder
and the founder doesn't give a damn
about anybody except making that company
change the world in the long run and so
they're given a lot of leeway like jeff
bezos or elon musk whatever
um i shall let me stick with with jeff
bezos on this one so jeff bezos he
doesn't even get on the earnings call
the quarterly call he doesn't care he's
long-term focused he doesn't care if
people are saying
well you're not going to be making a big
profit this quarter so you know i i
think we should find another ceo
no
investors are long-term greedy and
focused on bezos that's why they own
amazon
if he left that company point watch out
because what would happen is this like
it does with most other companies where
the founders all leave and are no longer
engaged
usually
what happens is
bureaucracy and politics
rule everything because if if you're at
a and it happened with with uh with
buddies of mine i worked at
hewlett-packard
you know they were senior executives and
they didn't want to take any risks
because you know they were getting a
nice paycheck and climbed the corporate
ladder and if they took a risk
and they created a new department or
product they they if they messed up
they're not going to get promoted
they're done
and if they are successful with that
they're not going to get paid a huge
amount anyway
so the status quo
is
keep being a politician collect that
paycheck you know grip and grin which i
despise
climb through the ranks
and and be political i hate it
but if the vander still there the
founder doesn't give a damn about
politics the founder is long-term
focused remember what warren buffett
said the longer the view the wise
intention
and they're not political at all so be
careful be careful about when founders
all leave a
company all right so please go to your
workbook
and on the first page as always
click on number 14.
uh and then um
spend three minutes writing down notes
on how you can apply the lessons
in section 14 to enhance your career
you've got three minutes go
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sales best practices
uh the best ceos are the best sales
people learn these crucial sales secrets
and i think i messed up the graphic i
mean it it looks the way it's supposed
to look but what i was trying to do
there is this is actually a setting from
the first movie blade runner 1982
classic
um and it's one of those chinese
restaurants that harrison ford ate at
anyway
i had a lot of fun doing this i feel
like an artist with this a crappy artist
i get it like i'm no uh
i'm no picasso and i'll leave picasso
here to give me a little bit of uh
inspiration and you got to do a search
on picasso quotes he's got great quotes
so anyway castle's my friend i have more
hair than him though okay
so um
yeah let's talk about these ones here
sales best practices number one is less
is
more
always
with corporate communications never have
more than three sentences ever again in
a paragraph
less is more keep it short and we'll
talk a lot about how to give a great
presentation and how to raise money
by having fewer bullet points on a slide
i'm telling you you don't have to work
as hard now three bullet points on a
slide because we can't handle more than
three things at a time uh on on a slide
when you're trying to raise money
whatever
uh and if you do try to use images or
some fun innovative way to do it
less
is more quite often people will only
read the first page of a very very long
report anyway
less is more
and if you have to write a big report
then you know try to
you know
try to have like a summary on the first
page or lots of summaries and i even did
this um
see the berlin wall behind there i even
did this with this book like i realized
that you know shorter chapters are
better like each no chapter i don't
think there's maybe one or two that are
longer on the page but a lot of them are
really really short
really really short you know less is
more and that's how people consume media
these days you know gone are the days
when you
gone are the days when when you read a 5
000 word editorial article in vanity
fair whatever it is or whatever
newspaper it is
less is more
that's why twitter is twitter
all right moving on oh yeah i started to
use
yeah movement here might be a little
distracting sorry
i want you to present with passion and
enjoy public speaking
condition yourself to love it and you'll
excel at it and most people are
terrified of it and i'm going to make
you into presentation rockstars very
very soon in the smc courses
enjoy it embrace it
all right next up is
shut up and i say with love my heart
speaking of the hardest up there i made
it smaller but it's still beaten
shut up if you think you close the sale
don't sell past the close
sometimes when you when you get the
impression somebody
loves a product that you're selling or
service
don't sell it anymore stop
stop right away
otherwise they're gonna think this this
is what will be going through their mind
okay
they'll be thinking oh gosh i love this
product i love this service gosh chris
is doing a great job selling i love it i
love it
why does he keep selling it am i missing
something am i a sucker why am i so
lucky to be given this opportunity i
don't trust him
i don't know oh no i do trust him i
don't i just don't know he's overdoing
i'm not gonna buy
next up is small clients are just as
much work as big clients and sometimes a
hell of a lot more
try to bag the elephant if you can go
elephant hunting
[Music]
that i don't mean that way but just try
to get big customers if you know what i
mean instead of smaller ones
um
because
small small customers are small
customers are more work than big
customers sometimes they have
more of their net worth with you and
that's why
um or they spent more money as a
percentage of their net worth on on the
product or service they bought from you
than a bigger customer just be careful
um you know i i i value all my customers
uh and i love them all sincerely i do
but
and for me it doesn't matter it's kind
of a moot point because all my customers
are the same right it's the same pricing
point always
but when i used to work um and i would
get customers
the biggest customers were the best
because the amount of time and
hand-holding i had to do with them was
much less because they were more
sophisticated sometimes as well yeah be
careful be careful
all right next up we've got all i heard
was not no
i want you to sell sell sell sell sell
sell sell and keep selling keep selling
keep selling keep selling until you
sense they're interested then stop
talking
until then keep selling selling selling
selling and tell yourself in your mind
all i heard was not no all i heard was
not no and don't forget to ask for the
sale like a lot of times people go to
meetings sales meetings and they'll talk
about their product
and they'll have a great lunch with
somebody whatever and they never ask for
the sale you gotta ask
but don't get discouraged until you hear
the word no
and by the way when you hear the word no
it basically means not yet
all i heard was not no
all right
next up
talk business later
bond as much as you can with your
clients a big rookie mistake is you show
up and you start talking business right
away you know business we know it's
about relationships first and product
knowledge second
talk business later okay
all right
how to get a meeting with anyone so the
route of how to get a meeting with
anybody
is as we know
you want to find something in common
with them right and the stars kind of
got all kind of a line for somebody to
take a meeting and and love you and do
business with you
so you want to
appeal that personal
personal motive so to speak
um find something in common with with
somebody you know um and and i talked
about how to get
informational meetings using linkedin et
cetera cover pages by finding something
you have in common maybe you're from the
same hometown
talk about your hometown
when you meet with them you know how to
conduct that meeting anyway
and talk about how your hometown has
changed or the schools change whatever
it is and what i was going to do
actually for for this uh
for this um
let me go back actually i don't want to
look at that baseball one yet now you're
all looking at the baseball ones we're
there let me go back here yeah so what i
was trying to do initially and i
couldn't find the right 3d models to do
it
was i saw this great movie ratatouille
and
great movie i'm sure you've all seen it
it's about a rat
that
makes good food
and there's a critic
a really really mean food critic that
comes into this dude's restaurant
and
the rat is nervous and so the rats like
what kind of food should i make
well i want to appeal this person's
background his emotions
and so what happened was the rats
made ratatouille i guess that's why it's
called that
uh it's and when the food critic you
gotta watch it man there's that one
scene where they they pull in and push
back at the same time on his face when
he takes a bite of the ratatouille and
he drops the
the the fork in in slow motion
and then the the food critic goes back
in time and remembers
growing up and his mom basically
touching his face uh and giving him
ratatouille as a child
i couldn't find that image so i looked
everywhere for it i couldn't find it
but you got to check it out
you got to appeal to emotions
and find something in common with
somebody as well it's a different angle
different way of thinking but it works
exceptionally well
you gotta yeah every battle's law
enforcement fought as you know
um and speaking of ratatouille so the
best restaurant in america
is called french laundry and it's about
a 40 minute drive north of where i live
here
um it's it's in napa valley i've never
eaten there it's too expensive for me
it's 500 bucks to eat there not
including alcohol
and
what rats what the folks at pixar did
was they actually went
to um when they were doing research on
the movie
all the kitchen scenes for ratatouille
were modeled exactly
after french laundry uh up in napa
valley it's pretty cool it's pretty cool
and speaking this is a good little side
note here but but speaking of um
speaking of pixar
in 2008
i went to a party here uh for one of my
kids
they were in the whole birthday party
phase between the first grade and fourth
grade whatever
and i met this guy at a house here in
hillsborough
and you know a lot of my best contacts
actually are through my my kids friends
parents it is what it is
and this guy at that point in time
he worked at pixar
and i asked him i said oh dude i'm a big
fan
what movie are you making next
he said well
it's this movie about this
old man
and this
short little fat kid
and
there's a bird named kevin
and
they throw some balloons on the house
the house goes up in the air and they go
on a journey
and i'll never forget what i said to him
i said it very politely i said this
i said
dude that's a merchandising disaster
like you're not going to sell any toys
like it's it's like
why would you why i mean the incredibles
was awesome you can make incredibles
part two three four five six whatever
you make a gazillion toy stories because
you know toy story you got all the toys
and my kid loved that that woody or andy
doll whatever it was
um and buzz lightyear
and he said to me he said you know chris
we don't make movies we think people are
gonna like
we make movies from our heart
we don't try to do it to make money it's
not about money
it's about touching somebody's heart
by using our own heart
and and
my goodness was he right
because up
that movie was the bomb i loved it not a
bomb it was awesome i loved it and the
soundtrack too by michael cameron's last
name but
oh my god and there's one scene from
that movie too where he goes his wife
passes away it's sad
but that like
three or four minute entire lifespan of
that guy's life
um when he was young when he met her to
the great pen he had remember the great
pen he had uh got married they couldn't
have kids and she passed away
i'm just getting shivers thinking about
the music just appealing emotions anyway
it was a great movie a little off track
there but
thinking with your heart is great
because if you don't think with this
this don't work this ain't gonna work
so always try to appeal the emotions uh
if if you can i'm gonna put picasso back
on the shelf here
all right good
all right next up is uh confidence uh
leads to competence i love baseball i
had to throw a baseball in there
somewhere
um
and
you'll never like
athletes do exceptionally well because
they're confident you'll never see an
athlete who's
who doesn't have confidence
especially in baseball where dude like
you've got somebody's throwing a ball at
you that's 100 miles an hour that's
curving it might hit you
you got to be confident
it's even harder in qriket dude because
in cricket that ball can bounce as it's
curving and then hit you
and and there's a windmill as well it
yeah you got to be confident i think
therefore i am
uh in lebron james
before each basketball game he meditates
and he thinks of himself shooting shots
getting in it over and over and over
again that's almost as good as
practicing
um confidence is a it's an attractive
trait
um
and for those of you that are trying to
get a date
if you don't come across as co i'm not
gonna i suck at dating but you gotta be
confident man
you gotta go in there ask somebody out
and just tell yourself i don't give a
damn if they say yes or no and if they
say yes i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna say do mind games never
you gotta
you gotta be confident you know what i
mean polite but confident too yeah
yeah
all right
so yeah confidence leads to a competence
if you believe in yourself um
there's there's nothing you can't do
and that's why on wall street they love
to hire former athletes actually a lot
of the time give me one second check
yeah all right
um they like to hire former athletes
because they're confident
and a lot of jobs on wall street you're
in sales
and if you're confident and you're
selling not arrogant but if you're
confident
then confidence leads to perceived
competence
all right next up is sports is crucial
boardroom talk it is it is
um and not everybody's a sports fan and
you can talk about movies and whatever
arts or whatever it is that interests
you
but
talking about sports
is i mean
i could talk to anybody in about
baseball at least if i meet somebody
from st louis you know i'll talk about
one of the best pitchers in history bob
gibson
if i meet somebody from baltimore
they'll talk about cal ripken the iron
horse and some of you might not know who
these people are
but i say this only because if you tell
me what city you're from
i i will immediately talk about a
baseball team in that city if there's
baseball and that's it overseas it might
be you know football like the real
football like the one you you kick
soccer yeah
um
don't
don't underestimate how important sports
is
you know that's why a lot of
corporations
they do a lot of sporting events like
they'll they'll take clients to to
tennis matches
um they'll
you know they'll rent out boxes at
football stadiums basketball stadiums
i've gone to a ton of hundreds actually
of baseball games and boxes
as well as basketball games too
in hockey games too when i worked at
golden we actually had a suite and maple
leaf gardens years ago yeah it's
important it's important and and i say
boardroom talk because there's always
before a board meeting starts you know
people are always just kind of hanging
out and haven't seen each other in three
months
board means usually quarterly
and you know
before the minutes i read from the
previous meeting and somebody says let's
start the board meeting you just chit
chat and usually talk about sports or
something else you have in common just
it's great for idol chit chat and you
can always go to somebody's um
twitter profile see if they follow
athletes i follow jesse barfield he used
to play for the toronto blue jays and
you can tell i'm a
blue jays fan it's it's
it's in my heart like i love it i love
it it's what my brother and
you know my dad and i have in common and
my kids love it too and it just
i just love it i absolutely love it
um and it's a great way to bond with
people as well and i remember in 1992 we
finally we won our first world series
typical american oh my god people can be
pissed off i don't care here we go
it's called the world series
because
well
it was always called the world series
even there's only teams in america
and they they put a team in toronto as
you can see there in 1977 that was the
first game
and then in 1992 we finally won the
world series in toronto and of course i
had that i got teased all the time by my
american friends who are very witty they
teased me about boots being canadian so
i teased them i remember that 92 after
on the world series i was like ah
ah yeah we won the world series yeah
who's who's the king now huh
and they said to me it was so funny it
was good
the retart was yeah so what dude
your americans beat our americans
i was like oh shut the [ __ ] up okay
anyway it was funny sports is crucial
boardroom talk yeah
all right
next up is golf often
and i know golf can seem expensive
it's not if you look around and play at
crappy places which is what i do
in fact my son dylan um
it was personal here
so my middle child here dylan it's like
a son of me i'll stop using the same
jokes over and over again i promise you
oh here we go you can kind of see it
there yeah okay i should use this one to
begin with
so uh dylan
this guy here in the middle
his golf teacher uh is a guy named matt
who's uh my videography i i hired him
he's a great guy he's a great guy i met
matt at crystal springs which is a golf
club where it cost you 30 bucks play
around it's a great deal it's a great
deal
um
but um and actually i'll talk about the
reason why i hired matt only because
he's editing this i'm just kidding
um so he was um
he's really social
and you can pick up a conversation with
him about anything anything nice guy
nice guy
um and and he noticed that i was reading
a book on
youtube and he said to me oh cool you're
looking into youtube whatever
and then i sized him up in 30 seconds i
knew i knew right away but he talked
about green screens and all this stuff
nice guy though nice guy more important
than anything else you know
relationships are more important than
product uh product knowledge
uh but but you got to make sure that um
if you can get on the links and golf
with people and don't worry if you suck
and you're new to it
so what so what i don't know like
get out there have fun with a couple of
buddies
you don't have to be me and by the way
i've learned a lot about people by
golfing with them if somebody cheats in
golf i'm convinced they're going to
cheat in business i've seen it i've seen
it yeah
yeah
golf off and uh if you can if you can
yeah
all right uh and it's always like i've
actually i've gotten some of my biggest
investors on the golf course
by accident
like they ended up playing with us on an
average course whatever
they're like hey do you mind if we
there's two of you there's two of us can
we play with you and i met people that
way
and they become my biggest investors
yeah it's amazing um yeah anyway
next up is
number 16 which is dress for success
it's so true
um
you got to play the part
like a lot of times before you get
promoted you have to kind of dress um
like
somebody one level above you very subtly
don't overdo it
um but you have to dress for success
and people will judge a book by its
cover
so
you know like in silicon valley it's a
little bit different here you can just
kind of be laid back and whatever wear
crappy clothes and people wouldn't be
wearing what i'm wearing
but i think it's important it's
important how you carry yourself
especially because you're not going to
get too much exposure to senior
executives right away
dress for success
all right
next up is leverage the media oh yeah
this is where i was going to come back
to it
so
mark benioff who uh
he's the founder of the largest company
here in san francisco called
salesforce.com and a wonderful
humanitarian
a good guy
i read his book called above the clouds
where he had a bunch of tips on how to
make it
and one of them was
leverage the media
and i first met mark i think a couple
years before salesforce went public in
o4
and
i i remember he was at all the goldman
sachs conferences when i worked at
goldman and then later on when i was a
client of goldman in the hedge fund
industry
and he was always on panels saying
software is dead software is dead cloud
is the future the cloud's the future and
we're all like i don't understand but he
sounds passionate so cool i like it
and he was selling something you can't
see feeler touch something virtual
something boring cloud computing but he
made it exciting
but he was being controversial it was
brilliant
by saying that software is dead
and
i ended up working in his building same
building
one market plaza here in san francisco
and actually i'd see him sometimes
walking his dog and bare feet his
beautiful labrador in bare feet on on
the main floor the lobby the public
lobby he didn't give a damn that's why
he's successful he doesn't care
and i remember once i went out to dinner
with him and i sat beside him before the
ipo
and we were up in the bank of america
tower on like the 50th floor uh and
i'll never forget he wore hawaiian shirt
he was just himself it's just mark it
was cool man mark with a c
and
it was a a a fee pricks or
fixed menu or whatever it is
and what happened was every time they
brought some food over he didn't want
he very nicely gently took his knife and
fork and put into a big x
but he was just himself but he leverages
the media big time and the way he
leverages the media is
he's controversial and controversy sells
and you got a network and i taught you
how all how to network uh using your
backgrounds and all good stuff linkedin
find journalists and meet with them okay
and and
be a little bit controversial as well
like for me if i were to do it
and i'm probably not going to
but if i did i would say
two-thirds of harvard business school
hbs two-thirds of hbs is bs
and if i went on talk shows and did that
i get some air time then they'd say what
about harun business school i said it's
a different age okay leave me alone
but i could do something like that or
like if you look at um
richard branson
when he launched virgin cola one of his
many virgin companies and he declared a
war on coca-cola and pepsi
he rented a tank in the early 80s
and drove through times square with
virgin cola cans all over it of course
you couldn't do that today
but he was controversial controversy
works
leverage the media as much as you can
because it's free advertising as well if
you do it right
all right next up is
please go to your workbook and click on
number 15.
the cover page meaning section 15.
then please take a boot three minutes
writing down notes on how you can apply
the lessons
in section 15 to enhance your career
you've got three minutes go
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
section 16
think
different i love this section i had so
much fun putting this together uh and i
wrote the top there crucial
highly profitable differentiation
strategies
uh and so
what you see here really shapes my
character
this changed my life
this computer here and i never threw it
out
um and so let me let me grab it hold on
a second
whoops
this here is from an old um
this is a before that mac came out this
is from apple ii which we had as a kid
and um
i just pulled this out for the first
time in
decades and on it here i don't know if
you guys can see it i'll read it you
probably can't read that uh but it says
um
getting older i gotta look like this
galaxian
um ms pac-man
hero and mario brothers and championship
load runner
yeah
oh and i took a hole puncher i remember
this i took a hole puncher here
so that you couldn't erase it i guess on
both sides or whatever it is this is in
the days when you take the disc out and
flip it but this here is from an apple
ii
um
and let me just put this down here
this thing changed my life okay
and and i remember when um
steve jobs decided not to
ship these things with disk drives
anymore and people thought he was crazy
he was thinking different he was
brilliant because of it
um i guess i can get a pin to take that
out there but whatever
um yeah this is ms-dos years ago but i
remember i was um i was younger and
they wanted to fail me in the sixth
grade in the eighth grade and it was
because
well they thought i had a learning
disability but [ __ ] them sorry
i have this gripe with teachers like my
school i went to when i was younger
it's a
well-known school whatever and they've
asked me to come back and give guest
lectures and keynotes or whatever it is
never i'll never mention them either i
think that a teacher should
not have an us versus that mentality and
look to look down upon students but
treat the student as a customer
uh and build their confidence
right that's
confidence is the most important thing
in business
one of the most important things
you know with confidence you you can
achieve anything last thing you need is
is a a bastard teacher trying to
bring you down
or a teacher that's just teaching so
that what they can do is they can do
research in university that's why i love
them teach um but anyway sorry there's a
lot of beautiful wonderful teachers in
the world okay most of them are sorry
about that off topic
but but they want to feel me and so i
went to this
it was a testing center uh in uh
oakville so my dad says oakville
ontario oakville
uh on lake shore road called chisholm
uh and they tested me there um whatever
i think they were wrong i think they
were but my dad bought me this and the
second he bought me this
everything took off for me i loved it i
had fun with it you can tell i like i
enjoy this stuff like i light up like a
christmas tree like tweety bird like i
enjoy this stuff
i love using technology and that was my
passion one of my passions i guess
but this changed my life this this box
here and the original ones if you open
it this is not an original one but if
you open it steve jobs and his whole
team signed everything and this is ice
put my mouse here i had a velcro on the
side and i still do that actually under
the table with other stuff yeah
um
you can see all the all the baseball
stuff and everything yeah so anyway
this thing here changed my life and so
it it's fitting that we now talk about
think different you know what i'll do is
i'll i'll leave this dude up here with
me
actually i'll put it back here because
that camera won't work
all right so so think different is the
title of this one here and i want the
galera to get in your face there
good okay
think different
and i used a product code called adobe
dimension to make all this stuff if
you're curious it's easy to use i can
show you if you care
all right so think different
so lesson number 90 we're almost done
is be a contrarian and watch your net
worth soar
um if you buy the same stock everybody
else buys you'll
i've said it before but
you won't make money in the long run
because who's the incremental investor
to push it higher you've got to be
contrarian
and just be aware of bubbles they they
occur
yeah and hundreds of years ago in europe
there was a tulip tulip bubble uh and
everybody chased the momentum and kept
buying these tulip bulbs which kept
going up in price an insane amount
um and if you weren't a contrarian you
you lost your shirt and human nature
repeats itself office all right next up
is
big companies cannot innovate
and i'll always bet on two girls or two
guys in a garage to change the world
uh instead of a big company always
always
small groups of people can always change
the world
always always always i think it's
competitive advantage and
jeff bezos the way he runs amazon
is he won't let any meeting take place
uh if
more than two pizzas are required to
feed the room that's why amazon's still
very successful they're big but they
kind of run like a startup
big companies cannot innovate remember
that to the same extent uh especially i
should say if a founder leaves i should
correct that yeah if a founder leaves
especially because after steve jobs left
apple as much as i love apple
what have they done
you know they they
made a watch which
is doing okay they don't publish number
of watches they sell because they're
probably not selling as many as they
thought they should have i don't know
i still don't know what the killer app
is for this thing i've i've got it or i
put it aside here actually it's over
here
um i wear it and i met johnny ive um at
um
san francisco moma dinner events we were
honoring him
um and right when before this thing came
out and i said to johnny i talked to him
uh and he's the the guy he used to the
british dude with a short hair
with with a british accent he speaks
good and all of us nice guy very serious
though
i asked him i said what's the killer app
for this
and he said
we don't know yet but perhaps the haptic
feedback which by the way is just
vibration that's what it means but he
sounded really smart by saying haptic
feedback he said perhaps that haptic
feedback will be a way for
families and i enjoy it i have the
product but
he said it's a way for say a husband and
wife they're in bed together
and not that but there's a newborn baby
in the middle sleeping with them
and um
the husband
gets up or the wife whatever to go to
work and if the alarm goes off it wakes
up the baby is disaster so
this is another way to wake you up
whatever because it vibrates on your
wrist but he didn't know what the killer
wrap was at at the time but but since
steve jobs god bless him has moved on
they haven't really done that thing
anything too radically different like
they made a bigger ipad
a thinner ipad a bigger iphone a cheaper
iphone
um
yeah so anyway i don't think that big
companies can innovate as much uh if the
founder has left so don't
don't ever feel
intimidated by a big company
because don't forget that
apple was
basically steve wozniak and steve jobs
in a garage
taking on ibm successfully yeah
yeah
so there it is there it is the computer
changed my life yeah
yeah
all rights
i'm going to show you this commercial to
you now
this commercial you're about to see
was only shown one time in history
it was shown
in 1984
during the super bowl
and 1984 is
the title of a book by a brilliant man
uh who wrote animal farm
um the man's name is is george orwell
about
an awful future
where
we're slaves to the government whatever
and so what happened was
this commercial was only shown once
and it was 1984 during the super bowl it
cost a million dollars to make and
ridley scott was the guy who directed he
did gladiator uh as well as top gun
um and um
it was brilliant it was brilliant and as
you watch it obviously you'll know which
character represents apple and which
character represents
big blue or ibm
uh and the woman actually that that um
represents apple um was uh sylvester
stallone's wife at the time so check it
out i hope you enjoy this and while you
watch it just remember that
one person or a couple of people small
groups people can destroy a big company
today we celebrate the first glorious
anniversary of the information
purification
we have created
[Music]
[Music]
shall talk themselves
on january 24th apple computer will
introduce macintosh
and you'll see why 1984 won't be
like 1984.
it's pretty powerful
okay
next up is the most important chart ever
made okay um and i know i've talked a
lot about a lot about a lot of important
things so far but this is the most
important thing okay so everything i've
talked about so far
is a bit important and we've seen a lot
of charts in business this one is
crucial please pay attention
okay
here it is
right here we have
pi i've eaten
and right here we have pi
i've not yet eaten
no
no i feel like that was phil dunphy from
modern family i i feel like that guy
people used to say that
they remind me of a i remind them of
phil dunphy that the father from the dad
humor stuff from modern family okay i'll
move on okay that was a joke all right
the real number 92 is this
ready
this is good this is powerful
form your own opinions dummy
all right and i'm saying dummy with love
my heart i don't want you to rely on
anybody
else's opinion i want you to rely on
your own opinions always you know you
you might think you're a cat adorable
cat like that you look in the mirror
you're not you're a ferocious lion
right you're you're king or queen of the
jungle nobody can touch you
vincent van gogh said if you hear a
voice in you that says you cannot paint
then by all means paint
and that voice will be silenced
arthur ashe
great tennis player
he said
one important key to success is
self-confidence
an important key to self-confidence is
preparation
over prepare for everything dude
everything and that will help with your
confidence big time if you prepare more
than anybody else does
for a presentation
or a sports match or anything in
business
you're going to enjoy it and you're
going to kick ass
every battle is warm for it's been fun i
think therefore yeah
next up eleanor roosevelt oh this is a
good one eleanor roosevelt
said
you wouldn't worry so much about what
others think of you
if you realized how seldom seldom they
do
it's powerful and if you guys want you
can do a screen print and all these too
let me go back a couple screens uh if
you want take a screen print
i'll go through it fast don't worry so
take a screen print here whatever
i'll give you three seconds to do it
next one here and you can put this on
your iphone or android handset as a
whatever
um
and then one more here
there we go
and eleanor roosevelt by the way she
also had another great quote which was
something along the lines of
they're going to criticize you anyway so
you might as well just do it
okay
oh i love this picture this one's
awesome look how adorable that cat is
you yourself
as much as anyone in the entire universe
deserves your love and affection
buddha
you gotta love yourself
mark twain he's great
he said 20 years from now
you will be more disappointed by the
things you did not do
than by the ones you did do
so throw away the bow lines
sail away from safe harbor
catch the trade winds in your sail
explore
dream
discover
brilliant
brilliant
all right
so form your own opinions please
all right number 93 is take that walk i
was inspired by gandhi with the salt
march uh and i actually tried to um i
tried my best to find one with a lot of
people following it cost a fortune like
i got a lot of these for free they're
royalty free but
there was one that cost a hundred
dollars that was tempted so i didn't
pull the trigger but but great man great
man but
so steve jobs
used to
go on these long walks every day at one
o'clock
and i do it as well and i put it on my
schedule a lot of times
take that walk
and when you go for a walk it helps you
to think differently
it helps you to release serotonin it's
it's like when you exercise when you
feel like crap
and then you do a little bit of weights
whatever or exercise
it releases serotonin in your brain
makes you happier
and
this thing rewards this thing
and a lot of my best ideas yeah i think
about when i'm walking you know i've
written entire courses
on long walks i used to take 12 to 14
hour walks
by myself uh it just it was
life-changing and it's fun too you can
bring some tunes if you want classical
music whatever
um
and then just go to a starbucks or tim
hortons or coffee shop like that
whatever it is
and just just collect your thoughts yeah
it'll allow you to kind of get outside
your own body and see the forest from
the trees and where you are in life and
where you want to be
yeah
all right next up we've got passion for
platforms that's a road
obviously
so the best type of business models you
can create are ones where you
you own the road
and
cars go on the road and you can charge
the cars or the toll booths kind of like
facebook is a platform for social media
i don't trust them
it's amazing facebook actually doesn't
publish anything
but they make money by publishing other
people's stuff because it's a platform
they're a tool keeper
airbnb
who'd have thought that the most
important hotel company in the world
wouldn't own a single hotel
their platform
same thing with uber who would have
thought
that the biggest taxi company in the
world now uber doesn't own a single taxi
they own the platform
that's how i want you to think about
business models
because once you own the road
then you can charge the car so to speak
and you get other people to be
incentivized to populate your platform
it's brilliant the ebay has done it
microsoft did with windows ios google
it's amazing it's incredible
all right next up we have don't respect
tradition respect innovation i was
trying to be innovative here as much as
i could
um
everything is going to be disrupted and
product cycles are getting shorter and
shorter and shorter now and disruption
is happening faster faster faster
but just don't don't respect tradition
i'm not saying you'd be a jerk whatever
but just
always question everything every product
can be disrupted
you know microsoft windows used to be
the most dominant operating system
platform on every device basically
and then windows ce never worked like
microsoft really should own
the uh you know
the smaller form factor operating system
market they don't they don't don't
respect tradition respect innovation
always always always yeah
i had a lot of fun making that slide
all right so please go to your workbook
and click on 16
on the cover page number 16.
and then spend three minutes as always
please writing down notes on how you can
apply the lessons in section 16 to
enhance your career you got three
minutes go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
section 17
it's crucial to find your passion
you be you it's a little cloudy but what
are we looking at there number 17
you be you we save the best for last
here
okay
so
i want you to be honest and speak from
the heart always
just be yourself
you know people might not remember what
you said but never forget the way you
made them feel that's a great quote from
maya angelou but just be you man just be
you
don't be a robot don't be data from star
trek you know be kirk
just your ursula just be yourself and
and when you're up there on stage if you
mess up whatever
you ever see somebody on stage they kind
of mess up a bit and you start liking
them a lot more
because they're a real
person you kind of like that just be
yourself don't give a damn what anyone
thinks
you got this far in life
and your family and friends love you
for being you
so why try to be somebody else
you know when you were younger in school
you were yourself everyone loved you
then you start working
you get older and you're in the
workforce whatever
and you're not being yourself
why what's the point
do you know that when a senior executive
walks by you in a big company and if you
if you suck up to them
or if you're not yourself
do you know that they don't respect you
more for that they lose respect for you
and even worse your colleagues hate you
for it
just be yourself
it's too hard to try to be somebody else
anyway
and as dr sue said the great thing about
having kids is when you read them books
at night sometimes i feel like the
author of the book is
is
talking in two languages one to me and
one of my kids
you know it's like the simpsons it's so
brilliantly written the simpsons when i
used to watch it my parents were around
my parents would laugh every now and
then when they were half paying
attention because it was written at a
different level like they would quote
old movies and stuff whatever
but dr seuss
he said
those who mind don't matter
and those who matter
don't mind
just be yourself
everybody else is taken
all right next up is listen to your
spouse
they love you
they fell in love with a certain person
that was themselves and that person
might have changed a bit
go back to being you
listen to your spouse
they will help you
they'll help you a lot
they'll be your your senate your sober
second look when you have an idea that
you're not sure if you should
pull the trigger on so to speak
career-wise
you know sometimes you'll look to get
advice from lots of people and you
forget
that your life partner the one you can
trust most in life
is right beside you remember why you got
married in the first place
you know only my wife can tell me
that i'm wearing a shirt that went out
of style eight million years ago i
thought plaid was still in in style it's
not apparently
or if i've dyed my hair too dark i'm
getting better now it used to be a
little bit too dark at times
um
listen to them listen to them yeah
so there's that guy too he looks kind of
cool it's funny
all right you be you listen to yourself
next up
don't let anyone rent space in your head
don't ever be somebody else's prisoner
don't give a damn what they think about
you
because
as you become more successful they're
gonna backstab you anyway and remember
unjustified criticism is nothing more
than a disguised compliment
get them out of your head
ethan
those who mine don't matter and those
who matter don't mind i had to say that
one again
don't let anyone rent space in your head
live your life to make yourself happy
don't live someone else's life to make
them happy
all right next up we've got
take time for you damn it
yeah
you got to schedule time for yourself
like when you make the the one pagers um
and you can always download that again
from
i'll tell you in a second it's kind of
complicated the link but i'm gonna show
you the graph in a minute but take time
for you like
i don't know if you're stressed out
like schedule time in for you to
unwind
and
binge watch
curb your enthusiasm if that makes you
laugh
or or
i don't rent that movie you've been
dying to see for a while
um or
take a day off from work and don't go
because you're mentally drained take
time for you
take time for you
schedule time for you
otherwise you'll burn out
and what's the point you're gonna make
yourself happy and if you don't laugh
every day you got to find a way to laugh
every day what made you laugh when
you're younger like when i started
today's lesson today's uh
lecture i sat in that chair
that made me happy
put yourself back in that situation
remember the trigger point the trigger
point is an event that occurred in your
life that made you so insanely happy
that when you think of it again shivers
just thinking about it and this this one
here this is the jose batista one here
and by the way if you're curious
these here are rookie cards for
dave steve uh and um
george bell another great blue jay
player and i have velcro because i put
them i have a man cave i built out the
attic by myself it's a hack job i don't
give a damn it's fun i learned a lot too
and i put these all on the ceiling every
blue jay card so anyway
don't grow up people
okay just be the happy you you were
years ago you be you take time for you
yes i collect baseball cards still
oh one up i love it i love video games
i love playing mario when i was a kid is
it mary or mario i always forget
and now when my kids ask me daddy can
you help me with super mario galaxy or
super mario odyssey's new one uh
ow
don't pull my arm too hard i'll be there
in a second and help you i love it i
love it
but i wrote here you're you're never too
old to start over you're never too old
to start over
you're not you're not
um
colonel sanders
he actually used to live in my hometown
of mississauga which is just outside
toronto which has a bigger population
mississauga than san francisco but most
people don't know it
but colonel sanders
he started uh kfc and it's interesting
it was actually for marketing reasons
they rebranded kentucky fried chicken to
kfc to de-emphasize the the letter f
for fry
but when um
colonel sanders he failed a lot in
business his entire life then he was 65.
way before i was born he was 65 and he
started kfc
and he made it huge he did really really
well
so you're never too old
to start over and people today are
living 26 years longer
than they did back in the 1950s
so if you're 65
you're not
you're 39
and you're never too young to change the
world as well
look at the beetles i've actually got
them can you see it up there yeah at the
top there awesome the beatles up there
that's abby road and by the way oh this
is awesome
the reason why um
the reason why they did that album cover
and it was so innovative at the time
because it was the first album cover
without the name of the band
but they were the most four recognizable
people on the planet
but i gotta i gotta go off script and
get this but they were gonna go to mount
everest because this was gonna be the
triumph their last big album
uh ended up not being their last album
and then what happened was they uh
i don't know life got in the way and
john was spending time with yoko and
paul is spending time with linda and
whatever
and they're like screw it i don't want
to go to everest that's a lot of work
man
so the name of the studio they were
recording was called abbey roads
and they walked right outside abbey road
and they're like
screw it let's do it let's just take a
picture here let me get i want to show
it to you
so the beatles and i have to talk about
this because you know the beatles
but they did all their brilliance in
their 20s in their 20s
unbelievable
so if you think you're too young
to um change the world
these guys did it in their 20s in their
20s it's unbelievable
and by the way if you're old older like
me
and you're you
you always wanted to start a rock band
outfit do it now you'll be the first 80
year old rock star someone's got to do
it we're living longer anyway so you're
not 80 or 17
54. yeah
all right
so um
i want to go through this here quickly i
want to show this to you all right so
abby road it's because it's cool and
we're going to study this in marketing
but i have to do it now i just have to
i'll show it to you here actually
what you've got here is they went
outside and they took a picture
and they learned that controversy sells
in marketing okay so what they did was
this
there was a rumor that paul mccartney
was dead there was a rumor he was dead
um in fact if you listen to the end of
strawberry fields and you play it
backwards
it says uh i buried paul
um although john lennon said it actually
says cranberry sauce it says i bury paul
they're messing around with the media it
and there's a rumor and then what
happened was that rumor spread for a
long long time
and here in sgt pepper's there's a patch
on paul's
shoulder here you see this
i got to make sure this the light's not
there okay good hold on right there and
people thought that said opd
but it actually like officially
pronounced dead opd that's actually opp
yeah you know me opp is ontario uh
provincial police opp because i used to
live in the province of ontario we call
them ontario party poopers
and then um right here i think this is
the best one to show here
let me get it right because this is
fascinating check this out this is cool
being controversial helps you sell like
mark benioff damn it okay here we go
so
you can see here this is a funeral
procession
uh and so john lennon is in white there
okay and he's the priest
then you've got uh ringo starr
the drummer
he's he's uh he's wearing uh he's the
pallbearer the guy that carries the
coffin
then in the back you got the gravedigger
which is george harrison
um and then you've got paul mccartney
who's in bare feet um smoking see the
cigarette there in his hand signal uh
signifying death because they even knew
back in the 60s hey man smoking's bad
and if you look closely
this here is a volkswagen beetle it's a
reverse here right right here beetle
it's clever
and the license plate if you zoom in
it's probably hard to see here
but it says
28 if
meaning if paul mccartney were alive
he'd be 28. they were playing around but
controversy cells maybe have to hold up
here and matt you can zoom in if you
want there we go yeah
yeah anyway so that's pretty cool and
even on the back people thought this guy
was a a skeleton or something whatever
it's pretty cool
pretty cool so um
it was neat it was neat yeah
yeah so
and initially with this album they
wanted to put which is oh my gosh it's
genius
they want to put it in a paper bag
george mart the producer did and because
they uh they thought they were gonna get
sued by people here bob dylan everyone
but whatever
a little bit off topic there but
interesting nonetheless
we gotta pull this over here cuz we're
gonna talk about this in a minute
all right we're still recording great
yeah so you're never too old uh to start
over again
right just remember that that uh john
lennon song starting over
um
and i actually met annie levitz who took
the the picture of john lennon actually
uh on and i got to show you really
quickly because i met her she's the best
photographer of the last century she's
amazing and she was at a benefit just
around the corner here um that i went to
and i got to meet with her and she she's
amazing
but let me show you actually so annie
levitz and there's a reason i'm showing
this okay annie leaves
i asked her also like i do with
everybody why are you successful
and she had some unbelievable things to
say
uh but you've seen a lot of her her
pictures right so um
yeah leonardo dicaprio you've seen the
cover of vanity fair demi moore and all
that stuff there she is there she's
wonderful
star wars she's the last oh right before
my goodness before she passed away
that's right just amazing pictures
but i asked her why are you successful
and she said because
her um my favorite actress in history
here
she said because
when i was younger
my father was in the army and we moved
around all over the world and all over
america and so i spent my youth
in the back of a a station wagon
a car
and i kept i saw america through a
different vantage point
because i was looking outside the window
and that window was a metaphor for a
frame for a picture right is that right
like that yeah yeah a frame
and so she thought saw things
differently
and let me show you um i'll show you the
john lennon picture she she took
actually uh on the day he died and she
my god this is brutal but the day that
john lennon was shot
um
she did a photo shoot okay
and she was working for rolling stone at
the time
uh and and she took um
like this picture here right is is was
one that's yokono and john lennon
obviously
it initially
um
i'll just show you these ones here so
initially yoko wasn't supposed to be in
the photo shoot
and john said no
she has to be and i only agree to do
this photo shoot if you put yoko on the
cover of the of the rolling stone
magazine with me
uh and so what what she did was um
this is it here yeah um this is this is
the cover here yeah
so what what happened was uh
he was some some jerk named mark david
chapman uh
took away john len's life with with a
gun at the dakota on the upper west side
in 1980 i think
and then after the guy shot him
after he shot lenin he was leaning again
i'll show you that picture there sorry
i'm going to scroll down
he was leaning against uh
a lamppost waiting for the police to
arrive reading catcher in the rye yeah
out there i know
but um
oh and so the editor of rolling stone of
course they wanted to put uh john lennon
on the cover
with something on the lines of
the the day the music died or something
um and um
just john lennon and he said absolutely
not yoko's got to be there as well i i
promised promised john lennon yeah but
she showed a couple more pictures how
she saw things differently like she took
a picture of nixon
um when when he was uh
no longer the president united states
and for those who don't know about this
richard nixon used to be president who
was no longer he was booted for lying
about something yeah
um and so she showed the picture she
told me how she
she wanted to think differently from
from the peer group
from other people and so she took this
picture here and everybody took the
picture of of
nixon going i'm not a criminal or when
he left her we were in the helicopter um
and you can go that if you want but
here's a picture she took which was
pretty cool
man and she saw she waited until nixon
was in the helicopter leaving the white
house launch she was there
uh there's the washington memorial right
there uh and she took a picture here of
these these three dudes here
putting their hands in her hat so that
that hat didn't blow away
which is pretty cool so anyway
yeah pretty pretty pretty interesting
but i had i had to pull the beetles into
that it's kind of cool it's neat i love
the beetles yeah
all right
let's move on now
number 101 frustration leads to
reinvention
and i had to end with my favorite pixar
movie ever with the best soundtrack ever
uh the movie up
um
yeah
yeah we're we had this this this older
dude whose wife passed away is sad this
grumpy old guy
and
he and a young guy
you're never too young to go on a great
journey and you're never too old to
start again and
they find themselves they find
friendship they
they meet kevin the bird
they they see a dog who's just like me
who goes squirrel
yeah so anyway
yeah
frustration leads to reinvention and and
i and i finished off my book there with
i think was on the last second last page
with frustration leads to breakthroughs
frustration leads to reinvention
find your professional passion
and end your frustration
welcome
welcome to the new you
welcome to whatever your name is version
2.0
welcome
all right so please go to your workbook
and click on number 17 meaning section
17 which is on the second page
of your workbook okay
then i want you to spend three minutes
writing down notes on how you can apply
the lessons in section 17 to enhance
your career you be you take three
minutes to do this now please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
homework time which
is in in japanese right homework in
addition to writing the quiz uh for
today's lecture like you do with with
all lectures
please use the contents
or or many of the uh the 59 lessons that
you document today in your workbook
uh and and apply them to your daily
schedule template meaning this bad boy
here this thing here okay
uh and you can download the daily
schedule template
in several different document formats
from this web address here all lowercase
as always
haroonventures.com
lowercase remember
pg-1-1-1 there's three ones there okay
three dash one dash one dash one uh and
like you did last class i want you to
alter the structure of this so it
incorporates
a lot of the 101 goals or or lessons
that you wrote down
so you can create your perfect life and
your perfect daily schedule yeah
we are now done with today's class thank
you